did you ever think you were made
Sweet Victory I know this life meant for
me
why would you bet on Goliath when we got
fed David value payment given values
contagious this world entrepreneurs we
get no value to haters
[Music]
okay so you know a lot of times when
you're you're doing podcasts and you
have a show you know you'll warm up the
guest and you'll say stuff you're like
people will say things here like I don't
know if this guy really means it or not
I am a fan of today's guest so I invited
him because I like listening to him I
don't agree with everything he says but
I like listening to him I like uh the
the history of his family his father
what they've done again this doesn't
mean we have to agree politically but I
I like the how United the family so I
said we got to get this guy on the
podcast we went back and forth I don't
know how long the team's gonna been
going back and forth uh with uh Chris
there's certain people that don't need
an introduction because when you think
of last names that are prominent last
names prominent families Cuomo is one of
those last names you don't have to
explain who it is you just say Cuomo
you're either gonna go to a place you
like respect you know these are great
people you're gonna go and say well I
can't believe they did this I can't
believe but you can't say you don't know
who they are Chris has uh Adam was
joking with them earlier saying hey you
know Chris are you getting nervous with
the lie you know I know it's not a first
time yeah I'm totally getting nervous
yeah Chris has been in front of camera
for for for a long long time and he
shines he's a star uh and his latest
show right now Cuomo airs weeknights at
8pm uh on news Nation he's got a YouTube
channel my favorite video on the YouTube
channel was when you got your 100 000 uh
the plaque that was sick the Chris Cuomo
project and we're going to put all his
accounts below go subscribe go follow
his show but with that being said we
have the one and only Chris Cuomo in the
house how you doing man thank you
appreciate the opportunity of course of
course Chris let's get after it let's
get after it so Chris you know uh
we got a lot of things to cover man I
want to talk to you about your pops I
want to talk to you about you know when
he announced he's running I did the math
I think you were 23 24 your your brother
was like 36 37 and what that
conversation was like behind closed
doors like Dad do it don't do it I'm not
gonna do it I don't want to do it you
know it's not my job it's somebody
else's job you know all this stuff we'll
talk about that we'll talk about some of
the stuff that went on with the media
and then we'll talk current politics but
I think it's important because Rob the
most controversial thing that we just
have to get knocked out of the way and I
think this there's there's nothing more
controversial than this can you pull up
the clip where you know it was very
disturbing video if you can play this
clip I want to get your reaction to it
and I got a couple props I want to bring
out Adam has no clue what it is Tom has
no clue what it is do you know which
video the video I texted to you Rob if
you have that if you can just pull that
up because we have to get to the bottom
here no no we're not doing a Ric Flair
video I think Rob accidentally opened up
other
windows that I texted him but this is a
video of you with your 100 pound
dumbbells okay and you're doing these
dumbbell presses you know you're doing
this stuff and you're doing the curls
you're doing the shoulders Rogan's
talking about it all these podcasters
are talking about it if you it'd be a
lot better visually Rob if we can show
it okay there you go uh uh uh a cow
originally responds to kolinsky we've
had him on the podcast before go ahead
omo is releasing videos of himself
working out yeah
100 pound dumbbells shoulder presses Is
that real yeah now watch this first of
all and then you got him doing hundreds
and then shows like listen to this
people are analyz
300 plus pounds and he's like he would
have to be one of the strongest men I've
ever seen in my life dude you're a news
guy what are you doing Chris
show us curl those okay if you can do
50s I didn't go to 60s no problem Cuomo
Fields no no I think he's got it but
this is real weight spots where I'm
having a hard time Olaf
what you got I will do this but nice
there's a bigger point right
um which is
clearly it's not a hundred pound
dumbbell right and in the video I then
hand it to one of my staffers and he
falls on the ground
um and it was a gift from a friend of
mine when we were starting the show
and what was interesting to me about it
I never said anything about it is the
Lust For gotchas and to make something
out of nothing which this is a joke this
is fine
um although I will do this because I
backed from no challenge but
[Applause]
that's pretty impressive yeah look at
60s curls there we go okay that's not
the point the point is not that I'm the
strongest man in news it's that kind of
is Chris no our lust for there's a
subhead coming after people for gotchas
I think it's a problem I I think it's a
real problem this was a joke
but
the desire to link it to and that's why
you can't believe this this I think it's
gotten to be too much of a contagion but
I'm happy to dispel that yeah well that
was pretty thank you for not having
hundreds yeah otherwise my shoulder
would be down here right now because you
actually curl what can you actually like
what controls you have a curled
dumbbells like 10 times probably that I
don't do arms got it I don't believe not
that I don't believe I'm old right I'm
going to be 53. I'm not a practitioner
of bodybuilding I think it's great if it
works for you enjoy yourself be careful
um but I'm all functional strength and
self-defense so I don't do a lot of body
shaping 20 30 years ago or 17 year old
now who I call Tarzan he's all about
gains and bodybuilding you know you have
the Core Power uh protein
seven a day he's bankrupting me on on
Core Power big is he now he is beautiful
Mario uh 17 my height you know he's like
our size he's still coming into himself
you know he's still light so he's always
like I want to gain weight how do I gain
believe me I was like life 17 dude life
on you that you'll never get off but he
is uh he is in full flower he's a
gorgeous kid strong strong strong but
that's what I found interesting about it
I can't tell you how many people center
right would say to me especially where I
live it's a big offshore fishing
Community I'm a Coast Guard Captain I
fish a ton
say
what was up with the dumbbell what was
up with the dumbbell and the you know
these like almost they they become
conspiratorial and it's it's sad to me
because it shows how fragile we are in
terms of how much we want to trust one
another but anyway thank you for that
it's always good to go for both sides I
mean both 100 do that what I am
impressed with not the dumbbell thing
but yes well you know we were gonna next
time we have if we have talk around
we'll bring some dumbbells out as well
to see what he would be the dumbbell
I don't think Tucker's curling 50s man
yeah no but but the point is you notice
your boy pbd didn't do it either oh he
can knock those things out
no I don't I'm not like I took that as a
challenge
I'm just saying that's a call out right
now I don't think you know how this guy
operates you call this guy out he goes
for it that's what PHP is all about
please do not pull a muscle right now
the show's over
if it does oh by the way he's one-upping
you Cuomo he's going 60s I did the 60s
oh you did that okay
Jesus that was good it was all right
that was impressive
big news politics it's like a bro down
right now but I like it I notice you're
staying in the chair also yeah I'm just
gonna kind of keep it cool I could do
one don't hurt yourself though
that's not bad yeah
Tom are you gonna skip this one
no when we do the mental weight lifting
we put a mental weight lifting okay I go
to the bathroom now
four things how you doing how are things
with you obviously you know we followed
the story you know when you make
comments you know you're going through
uh one day you're the guy every day
we're listening to you on the next day
poem announcement comes out but how are
you doing right now I appreciate you
asking the things that matter most are
good right families healthy uh
everything's stable very traumatic
period everybody goes through something
in life and people have gone through a
lot worse than the cuomos but uh you
know
sudden disruptive negative forces in
life have to be dealt with and they take
time and you just have to make sure that
you protect what matters most I lost a
little control of that I've never seen
the media
chase after someone in the media the way
they were with me in the aftermath of
that my brother I guess was like better
at hiding you know like they couldn't
find him the way so they were but like
six seven eight cars of Paparazzi
following my kids harassing my wife
harassing my kids
um you know all the Tabloid junk and
lies I just wasn't used to it being put
on me you know we don't usually care
about people in the media that much but
I guess there was something a little
um a little Transcendent about the
family
um and you know you deal with it we have
the benefit of perspective you know
being in this business I've seen so many
people come through so many horrible
things that this was really nothing
um and that perspective helped I then
had a real issue with what to do because
my concern was well what job
what I get that to me would be growth in
the business
you know I had had a very good run of
doing different things so then I came
down the point of purpose about why I do
it which is why the podcast is a lot
more about what I think is a very
relatable sense of how we very rarely
talk about the most uh transferable
experience in our lives which is
struggle everybody struggles you
struggle with your health you struggle
with your finances you're going to
struggle and we don't talk about it a
lot because we see it as weakness we
don't talk about emotional struggle
because we see it as weakness especially
men
um so I just made a decision that if I'm
going to do this
and deal with all that comes with it
I should do something that I believe is
truly going to help in a way that at
least matters to me
so
you you know you imagine the the
dumbbell BS times a million and that's
what you get when you talk about uh
feelings of depression
or insecurity
um or how to struggle you know people
immediately in you in the media if you
are sensitive or vulnerable you get
attacked for your vulnerability which is
why so many people stay quiet especially
when they're having uh struggles they
stay quiet because they don't want the
stigma they don't want to be seen as
less than they don't want to attack my
feeling was what else are they going to
say at this point if I think it's going
to be helpful to people I want to talk
about things you know people in my life
say well you know careful on me you talk
to a therapist thing because people are
going to think you're crazy and I said
all right well maybe they're right I
said but the point is that's exactly why
you do it you do it because it's such a
great tool in my life this guy's become
like a life coach for me
um funny story for you guys my therapist
started out as a couples therapist and
after that first wave of couples therapy
where the husband traditionally takes
the beating
um
they both decided yeah because you know
they both decided about Couples Retreat
is what I think I don't know if you've
seen the movie the the both both of them
decided that my wife didn't have to be
there anymore honey I'm going to be a
while so he became my therapist and he's
been my therapist for you know a long
time he's like a life coach best tool I
have I want you over he won you over as
a one-on-one you want to spend time with
him I believed him
I I do believe him that he said look uh
if you want to if you want things to
work in your life you have to do
everything you can to work on yourself
and make accommodations everywhere that
you can and that is a skill set
and you know it's great to be a natural
fighter and to be great with
confrontation uh it has limited
applications uh in your personal life
you know you don't want to take on every
argument if you want to stay married or
you want to be a good parent you got to
learn how to shut your mouth and listen
and let things play out and I was never
really good at that before I started
that process and then when I went
through the down
he said to me you know it seems to me
that we keep coming back to a similar
cycle of emotions for you and I think
that you're having a hard time
regulating how you feel about these
things and I would like to try uh after
we've talked this out for a while I'd
like to try you on an antidepressant and
see if it helps you with your kind of
balance of how you're feeling because I
would have like big lows like you know
I'll never be what I was look what I did
to the family I'm getting attacked for
helping my brother I didn't even really
help him you know what I mean because
look at the situation he's in so it's
like I failed I failed to fail I failed
and so then I was like okay you know
let's take it give me all of it I want
you know I want all the smoke and he was
like no that's not how these works we
start with a small dose I was like no no
I'll take the big dose whatever the big
dose is I want the big dose and
um obviously I learned
about how it really works and I was like
you know I should talk about this
because he said you know a lot of people
won't go on medication because the
stigma and then I'm in this training
course
for this coast guard certification and
they're talking about how you're going
to have a pee test you know in a drug
test and all that stuff all the protocol
and I say hey
what about if uh you're on like
medication do we have to list that stuff
and the guy's a great guy who did the
course and he's like what do you mean
like crazy pills or something like that
and I was like yeah like crazy pills
what if you're on that and I was
laughing when I said it because there's
no shame I have no shame in my game I
know who I am I know who I'm not Pat did
you know like we talked before the show
because I saw your Kanye West interview
yeah and you kept reverting back number
one you called him Kanye West multiple
times it's yay it's yay I didn't even
know he changed his name right and with
no difference you kept addressing not
only the anti-Semitism and stuff you're
you're like are you are you addressing
your mental health and you were very
open you're like listen I take my
depression meds every day right you
leaned into it uh well but I think it's
like you know we're living a lie here
that it's an exception uh you know
depression is by most people's calculus
a leading illness and diagnosis in our
country my concern with yay and he
called into the show I didn't know that
was going to happen I don't like putting
people in distress on television one of
the biggest opportunities I missed in my
career was when Charlie Sheen was all
the rage about the Tiger's blood and
winning I had uh common friends with him
and there was no question and again no
disrespect to him because I don't think
talking about somebody's health is
really anyone's business but uh they
were clearly stability issues there that
had to be so I wasn't going to put that
on TV
because I I felt it was Fanning the
Flames of seeing that as less than
seeing that as a carnival act and I
didn't want to do that and that's my
concern with yay also is that people
take what he's saying
as if it was coming from a sober mind
and that's dangerous in terms of uh
discounting somebody's illness
and it creates a baseline for what's
okay to scrutinize that I don't agree
with
anyway the short answer is uh
everything that matters is okay and I'm
excited about building something at news
Nation I've never done that before you
look like you're having fun which is
very good I mean when I when I see your
podcast stuff it looks like you're
having fun with your YouTube channel the
YouTube channel podcast is new for me
it's the only thing I've ever done
professionally that is only what I want
it to be you know I pay for all of it I
just started doing ads which happen to
be my favorite part of it I've never
done an ad in my life like live reads
Yeah well yeah I mean it's not the
performance of it that's that's all easy
but the it's if I like it I say yeah
like you know the age of the living
green things ag-1 stuff I mean really it
works for me I'm a huge supplement guy
and it's really hard to get the mixes
right and what your body's actually
going to absorb and not and what makes a
difference
um you know like gut health inflammation
all these things that like beset ethnic
Bloodlines
um I'm into it so it works for me so
I'll say it so I get a lot of offers for
advertisers where I'm just like well
this sounds like a [__] thing you
know so I'm I'm not going to use it I'm
not going to say so have you done
manscape yet have they reached out to
you yet because they're gonna reach out
if they have they're not gonna first of
all no this is very important question
my son has a manscaping kit that I got
him so there you go
um the 17 year old he is his game is
strong I am like I am like a drop Jean
Italian I am one of the most hairless
attack I'm like them you know the
Mexican hairless Chihuahua I am that
version of an Italian yeah you don't
have any arm hair going on I had more of
a mustache than nice hot by the way real
quick shout out to our sponsor today
manscape I'm just kidding no no no we're
not doing no man no no no well by the
way you've done it before you've done
asking because I want to follow up on on
some of the questions here uh with you
uh so you're saying you know I'm going
through this you know how sometimes you
talk to people like look 38 years old
I've never had any allergies and then
all of a sudden I got this allergic I
never thought I had a allergy to this
allergy to that the other day Vinnie is
having shrimp his lip becomes like this
ridiculous lippies and everybody thought
it was a prop and it was his lip but
he's 44 years old he's got this slip and
so
was did you have a track record in the
in the past of being depressed or going
through this before or was this like
what's this all about I'm a I'm a tough
guy I can handle something like this or
was it like man I'm tough on the outside
but man deep down inside I got some
insecurities and I've been hiding it
very well and people don't know about
the fact that I'm afraid of this or
Shadow this or that can I be the man
that I want to be what was it for you I
think that it's a great question by the
way uh and I think that there is a
tendency to confuse personality uh with
uh your chemical balance right and one
will there's certainly correlation
uh but my obvious and you know I'm very
blessed with a lot of very long time
friends
um who will say to you oh no this guy's
had problems ever since but personality
flaws aside I had never this this is
really the truth here's what really
knocked me sideways I did not see this
coming
I knew the moment that I had my brother
on during the pandemic I was going to
pay a price
uh and anyone who's around me remembers
me saying it remembers me saying it to
my brother when he was you know Captain
kovid and the love gov and all this
stuff I said enjoy this because there is
an immutable reality in media you told
them this oh yeah if you are going this
way you are going to go this way and I
said it to him my brother is uh friendly
and more than collegial with Governor
Christie and when Governor Christie was
having his first love up you know you
remember that when like he was like the
new Giuliani and he was tough and all
this yeah before the bridge I would say
to Andrew
listen it's an immutable truth in media
if they're looking for reasons to bring
you up they're going to look for reasons
to bring you down and if circumstances
allow it's going to happen we saw it
happen there uh happened with Andrew I
did not anticipate how it happened with
Andrew but I knew I would pay a price
for having him on
because it was an obvious
conflict now the reason that I was okay
with it was one my bosses really wanted
it
um Jeff Zucker yeah and I I don't think
he made the wrong call by the way but I
knew that the media would say well
you're having your family on the
interesting thing was always the
disconnect between
the pbds of the world and the
journalists of the world I have been in
the business a long time I've won almost
every piece of lucite they give out in
television journalism
I've never had people thank me for
anything in terms of the value of work
as they did for the work with my brother
and when I was sick it's not even a
close contest the number one thing that
people say to me when they see me is
thank you for how you helped my family
during covet thank you
um nothing else even comes close so
because I knew that that was the
feedback of people saying you know I'm
so afraid of so-and-so getting sick I
got this old person I got this immune
compromised person
um thanks for letting us know what it's
like to have it
I was okay with it but I knew I'd pay a
price
I just couldn't have anticipated what
took my brother down and the opportunity
the media would have to scrutinize me I
didn't see it coming and as a result
when it came
something I'd always Define myself as
which is really good at anticipating
what's going to come and how within
media and politics I was kind of
blindsided by it and everything that was
said about me didn't make sense it
seemed like
this is I don't know how you could
believe this this can't be true you may
not like that I helped my brother you
may not like that I had him on TV you
may think it was a sin of Journalism but
obviously it was what my boss was okay
with otherwise it wouldn't have been on
TV and I never lied about helping my
brother I told the audience the audience
got it nobody expected me to objectively
cover my brother I never did my
interviews with him were in
accountability interviews nobody would
accept that my mom loves more and who's
this and yeah I mean you know he was
just wrong about all of that but that's
okay but but that's look it was what
people I felt were really benefiting
from in that moment of the familiarity
of it I just didn't see it coming so you
know Patrick when you don't see
something coming
it is much more damaging you know what I
mean so like the the the the hook can be
half as powerful as what your jaw can
take but if you didn't see the hook
coming terrible it's destabilizing as
much as it is injurious so that's what
it was for me I didn't see it and it
gave me an opportunity that
I don't wish on anybody but was really
helpful I got a good chance to go back
to zero of everything that you had that
you may have valued
is gone
so now what do you really value what do
you really want to do what do you really
want to be about because you're starting
over
at 50 something whatever I was at the
time 51 whatever and
that's not easy I don't wish that on
somebody but I believe very much that
there are no problems uh in life there
are opportunities they can suck they can
be great they're still about what you
make out of them I want to go back to
the question I want to go because
there's a question I want to ask so so
uh uh in this setting
your your dad is a beloved admired
respected even when he called out his
opponents he would say well you know Mr
such and such has these views but my
views are this it wasn't what politics
is today it was a no very classy he was
the Reagan of the other side is the way
I would put it he would be lost in
politics today yeah he would be law in a
positive way or in knowing a negative
way he'd be lost oh he individually he
wouldn't understand
how you can say not pbd but that how an
opponent all right I disagree with your
tax policy I disagree with your
immigration policy let's get something a
little bit more visceral okay
um but I get it you know your first
generation American so I'll give you a
little bit of a break but uh you're a
bad guy who wants to see my daughters be
raped and they said my father wouldn't
have known how to he would have had to
fight you know he would have been like
oh you just said I want your daughter to
get raped we have to fight because he
wouldn't have understood that level of
insult
um that is just divorced and devoid from
any sense of reason so what you don't
want to argue my position you just told
me that I don't care about your your
child yeah that's not who he was that's
all our politics is now which is
um you know it can't be that Bobby
Kennedy Jr whom look I haven't been
interviewing him people say I'm afraid
my brother was married to his sister
yeah for a long time they got three
beautiful kids Terry Kennedy yeah I care
about her I care about him I've known
Bobby most of my life
um and I wish him well but the last
thing I need is to get hit in the head
with another stick of conflict so that's
all it is there's I've talked to Bobby
about what he's doing in his campaign
it's not that Bobby Jr should be called
crazy unstable it's the vestiges of
addiction he's this he's a spiritual
candidate it's judge's positions all
right if you don't like what he says on
this tell me why don't I don't want to
hear your character analysis of
everybody that you disagree with that's
where we are now and we're there because
it works better when you describe your
dad you know you know to Armenians when
I first came to America I'm Armenian
Assyrian you know when they say hey
you're such a [__] you say that
to an Armenian they're thinking you're
saying you want to screw their minds
like wait a minute what did you just say
so you have to fight them right it's a
literal mindset like it's we take it
literally you don't talk to me like that
so I can see what you're talking with
your dad being old school and yeah it's
old school but also that's how it was I
remember a situation so he is in a
budget battle that was like existential
okay with the head of the New York State
Senate who was an another Italian guy he
has them over to the governor's mansion
right they open a bottle of wine
uh and I know it sounds you know
stereotypical but whatever this is what
happened and they Ralph Mourinho they
are going at it okay but it is no your
mother this you know or you know you're
a pedophile there or anything crazy like
that it's uh Marina wanted to make a
deal my father in truth my father was a
gifted speaker or Raider
um he could capture people's imagination
he was not a great politician he was not
a great deal maker you know he was a no
what I want to do is write what you want
to do is wrong so you know I I think my
brother actually has much better
political skills of understanding where
a midpoint will be sooner than my father
did
um but they made they made an
accommodation for each other they saw
each other as both coming from a good
place of what they wanted they did not
agree on how but they would figure
something out that does not happen now
because it is enough for you to say you
have to stop Cuomo forget about what I'm
gonna do forget about what you're going
to do forget about your position forget
about it whether it works forget about
whether it's reasonable forget about any
of that I have to stop this guy because
he's a danger he should frighten you
and you wonder why it's a battle to the
bottom that's why when did this change
Chris because what you're talking about
this is the 80s
um okay let me do this before we go one
or change this this question I still
haven't got an answer I really want to
understand this part as a father of two
sons so for me this is what I want to
understand so I asked the question
depression wise had you in the past had
a friend of me okay so that's so that's
a no no so this all of a sudden happened
like I was caught off guard so yeah okay
so then the question would be on this
topic before we move on to the next
because you said so much man you talked
about I'm sorry I don't mean this is a
long from a long form podcast which
produces more content you talk about
covid how you've never had anybody come
to you the way they do in the covet
situation your brother when he was
Limelight every day we thought he's
going to be the next president I got
questions there and I got a couple other
things you talked about podcast TV but
but the question I want to ask is your
dad is Mario Cuomo gives the speech I
want to say 84 and he has a moment like
Obama has an o4 20 years apart give or
take and then all of a Suds like this is
the guy and and not only the a guy
that's going to be a governor he's going
to be the first Italian president you
know Etc et cetera he's got the swaggery
He's Got Confidence he can negotiate
behind closed doors then it doesn't
happen was there ever from your father's
style of leading you and your brother
and raising you guys did you ever feel
there was a shadow there of him as well
as your brother because your father
became a two-term your brother became a
two three terminal I'm sorry he also ran
for Ford my apologies he was a
three-term your your brother was a
two-term you're the guy that's a star on
TV everyone knows the last thing Cuomo
was there any element of a shadow from
Pops or if not what did he do to not
create a shadow type of an environment
um the answer is going to be very
different based on the brother right
Andrew is in political life he believes
in the marrow of his bones that whatever
comes with public service is worth it I
would not be surprised uh if he decides
to get back into elected office I do not
I worry about that as his brother and
someone who loves him and someone who
feels that he's given enough and dealt
with enough I've actually felt like that
for a long time but he just believes
that this is the best way to help and
that's all pop was about is there a
shadow
I would reverse the metaphor and say I
think that there's a glow
um you know you don't have to agree with
my father's politics I didn't agree with
some of my father's politics that's okay
but he was a good man who did things for
the right reasons
um and I I uh love that I am privileged
by that I
um I'm very proud of my family name I'm
proud of what my mother has done and my
sisters I mean they're the really
talented people in the family we just
talk uh Andrew actually does public
service proud of him proud of how he's
handled this situation
um but so it wasn't Shadow it was shine
and it
compelled Andrew to want to do the same
kind of work
it caused reaction formation in me where
I would never do that kind of work you
would never do I would never really go
into elected office why is that too hard
on me and my family as kids
Too much exposure to things that you
don't control that you don't deserve
that you're not responsible for too much
ugly compromise
too much having to smile and shake hands
with someone that you know doesn't
deserve it because you believe in a
greater good
too much money and the need for money
even what we're seeing with Biden right
now the best thing he has going for him
is that the DNC has fundraised
competition out of the picture
so they know they can't match the ads
and ads are what five seven to one
negative to positive which means I'm
constantly burying pbd under something
that may or may not be true but it's
getting a lot of time
yeah um that's the best thing he is
going for him my father hated it the
worst thing you could do
is give money to my father and then ever
want to meet with him again you know
because he was like no I can't if you
hadn't donated PB I would have talked to
you about what you're doing with
valuetainment I think we could help you
here in New York wow now I can't talk to
you
so he was different
um
but it was shine not Shadow and Andrew
and I came to very different conclusions
I respect his it's stronger
uh there's there's more grit and
goodness in the decisions he's made than
I have
um but I'm okay with that and that is
another reason that I got knocked so
sideways so that here I am saying I made
a decision that of course I'm public
facing and of course but I didn't think
I had set my kids up to pay the price
that they wound up paying because of me
and it killed me it killed me the reason
you know this stupid video that is out
there of me of Shelter Island where
they're these three guys they make it
look like it won but it was three uh
coming at me about calling me Fredo
here's what bothered me about that one
and I'm sure you can agree with this
in front of your nine-year-old daughter
somebody calls you something that is
offensive to you as in a Syrian Armenian
okay they say it to your daughter
okay now you tell me if all that follows
is a conversation so first of all they
leave that part out the media left it
out why didn't serve their purpose yeah
they wanted me to be a big Italian
hothead you know muscle man who wanted
to beat up this one little guy it was
three good-sized guys who stopped a
nine-year-old girl and said hey you
think Fredo will take a picture with us
now she didn't know what they were
saying yeah the edited narrative strikes
again but I been talked to them yeah I
was cursing and I knew he had the camera
out I'm not a fool you know but I didn't
care because I thought the point
mattered and I'll tell you something
couple years later Rob can you pull up
uh the video just so some people can see
what it was a couple years later I'm at
a restaurant and I see this young woman
looking at me kind of weird
I kind of look over and look back I'm
with a buddy of mine
and
all of a sudden I see this guy standing
next to her which is one of these guys
one of the three uh and he comes over
and he's like hey I just want to say I'm
really sorry about that I didn't know it
was going to go that way I didn't know
that I didn't really recognize him at
the time but then I did and I shook his
hand I said you know what you don't have
to apologize the situation was
ultimately on me I'm the adult I'm the
TV guy I should have known what was
going to happen but I just didn't give a
[__] because at some point
there has to be decency and people will
say you're talking about decency you
would threatened about you know the
difference between me saying I'm going
to do something to you and me doing it
that is a Grace
okay that I'm going to tell you what I
should do to you but I'm not doing it
that is a Grace okay
um and I thought it was an accommodation
I was actually proud of myself I
actually called CNN and told them that
this happened right after it because I
was like but I didn't touch anybody I
didn't touch anybody one of the guys put
his hand on me and I said I'm telling
you take your hand off me and I gave him
the warning he took the warning but
I understand why it blew up in my face
especially when the former president
decided to weaponize it and use it
against me as if I was the threat not
him
um
but in context the kid saying it to the
kid
um is just too much for as you're saying
this Rob if you can go just show five
seconds of it just show five seconds of
it whatever with a little bit of audio
uh Elan if we can go you don't see my
daughter yeah you don't hear the part
where I say you say that to a
nine-year-old
punk ass [__] from the right call me
Fredo yeah my name is Chris and he said
I thought that's who you are you thought
my name was Fredo yeah you can pause
this so we're in the back let me tell
you what's going on the back
so we're going through all the stories
uh are we bringing this up are we
bringing that what's the last thing I
said what do we talk about at the end
you're like yeah I don't want to bring I
don't care about bringing this up okay
so you brought it up but let me tell you
what I did say I see you know somebody
and you asked the question I think it's
somebody comes and says what would you
say I said dude probably a very similar
reaction if you're gonna try to do
something with my family but believe it
or not this did nothing for me I think
Trump's just an opportunist he saw it
boom capitalize run with it but and what
Trump wasn't my problem look
I have known the former president most
of my adult life sure my mother and his
mother went to the same beauty parlor
okay wow your moment yeah and
um it's the idea that I have a personal
animus towards a former president is
just simply untrue I don't like that he
made me a personal Target because it
affected my kids and I live in a trumpy
place
so I didn't need that he could just
judge the work I always had him on I
always offered him interviews people
would hate me for giving them he would
come to you he did for a while and and
then he did and that's okay also
um he would continue to contact me after
uh that complaining about CNN or
whatever it was and I would be a fair
broker to him to tell him why it was and
who it was I would have his supporters
on I was the only show at CNN or
certainly the show at CNN the most who
had on Trump supporters
always and I've done it at news Nation
also because I believe in more dialogue
not less I believe that if you have an
idea that I don't like I don't censor
your idea make the case let me test the
case try to disagree with decency don't
let it get personal and if you make it
personal call out that you're making it
now you're making it personal and that's
a sign of a weak argument and I've
always done that so I don't have a
personal animus
um against him I'm not surprised he did
that that was the right play they're
saying that you're a tough guy and that
you're making people angry look at your
boy
I get to play what I didn't like was
that my brothers and sisters in the
media ignored the context and allowed me
to be displayed as something that I'm
really not but look that's the price
you want to be in the media this is the
price don't complain so I didn't
complain as a kid when you were a kid
because you said something you do I
don't want to get into politically
sometimes you know how a family of like
a general crystal is a four star but his
dad was a two-star this other person was
a tooth like you're like oh okay I kind
of got to do it and there's typically
that one kid's like dude I want to have
nothing to do with [__] yeah put me
out of that [__] I don't want to go in
the military I don't want to go into
Hollywood I don't want to go into this I
don't want to go into that so was it how
they treated your dad you're like I
don't want to do this part was it the
element of hey Chris in school when they
ask you this you can't say that you know
in school they would come up I can't
believe your dad is a this your dad is a
dad is it that element where you're like
I just don't want to deal with a little
bit okay um you know as you you and you
can I identify I don't know your guy's
backgrounds the same way but my father
and his family had such immense Pride
that he could be in the position that he
was you know his parents were illiterate
um and I don't say that insulting they
just didn't have the opportunity so for
him to be this and to serve and to be
able to be a voice and let alone such an
eloquent voice you know I mean your
mother and father are struggling to put
together a phrase in English and you
were one of the best wordsmiths of your
Generation The Pride and the service uh
there was there was no shame there was
nothing but uh what an amazing
opportunity what a privilege and so I
ever always took whatever came with it
that way one funny story my father so
we're in Hollis right my father becomes
Governor whatever that means because I
didn't really know what he did you know
I'm 12 years old you know so I mean I
knew he was a lieutenant governor I
don't know what that means this guy in a
car and he leaves and he was away a lot
my father worked
um my father worked
uh first second and third his priority
was the gig because he felt that was the
service to give back because of what his
family the opportunities family had been
given here
and
very ethnically diverse Place very tough
Place uh not not like the hood or
anything but it was a place where any of
the things that our kids existed today
didn't exist where I was there somebody
came up to you and talked [__] to you
where you had to defend yourself it was
never going to end
so when my father became Governor all of
a sudden I got hit with like one of the
worst things that could be said about
you where I grew up which was Scott
thinks who he is now and I didn't even
know what you know what I was what does
that mean who am I exactly but that's
not how it worked so one day I'm getting
chased from the uh bus stop back to my
grandmother's house I spent a lot of
time with my father's parents once he
got into uh politics because nobody was
home so I you know I stayed with my
grandparents around the corner and my
grandmother is sitting at the front door
of her house and I'm running
away from like three three kids four
kids me I don't know and I run up the
stairs to her house and she sees the
kids chasing me and goes click on the
screen door lock you out yeah and she
goes
you're kidding me like that so I wanted
you to fight them yeah she's like you
know she just went like this
and pointed at them and then like on the
front lawn right in front of there it
was like me and these three guys like
kind of rolling around for a little bit
and then uh and you remembered us
vividly yeah
yeah I always tend to remember an ass
beating and
thanks grandma and she was like you
don't run away from your problems and
she was right you don't run away from
your problems you may lose
you may lose they're going to respect
the fact that you faced them it what are
they doing they don't do you respect
yourself I 100 absolutely the question
here before we move on Mom and Dad
married 60 plus years yeah and you know
uh uh I asked uh Robert uh RFK years ago
when we did the first interview tell me
about the values at night you know what
it was like at dinner table etc etc I
asked President Bush when we had him
once I'm like hey what was it like you
know what was family like what was your
grandfather you know whether it's you
know did you guys have certain rituals
Traditions you know what you guys did uh
what was you know your at dinner mom dad
sitting there at the dinners that Dad
was at least home because he's always
away working but when you guys were at
dinner what were some values your dad or
your mom passed down to you what was
conversation like did he bring up
politics did he bring up real issues hey
Chris what do you think about this hey
what do you think about that I know you
and your brother's age difference is 13
so I don't know if like that would
happen a lot but what values and
principles did he pass on to you
the picture tells you everything
although every one of my siblings will
hate that you're using that picture
um
family
a family it was all the typical travails
of family I was the only one in that
family
that had parents who had the ability to
pay for any of my education Andrew
worked his way through college in law
school Margaret the oldest all
scholarships well she just they were all
amazing students
um you know money for school loans for
school you know local colleges I was the
only one who went away for school
so I had a better
um Family setting than than they did it
was much more middle class for them and
uh family you don't have to like each
other all the time you're not going to
like each other all the time uh you are
there and if there's trouble
you're there there is no why there is no
go and my siblings
have always been there for me no matter
what it is there's never discussion
until after and then you'll have a
discussion about what they helped you
with or out of but it was a very
traditional Italian Catholic Queens you
know uh life uh where what my father
worried about were the simple things
there was no high-minded you know do you
think we should be a Democratic Republic
or do you think that there should have
been some
um there it was not lofty stuff he
certainly thought and read and wrote
about that stuff himself
but it was
simple how you doing in school you know
him taking an assessment of whether
you're talking back to anybody around
which wasn't going to happen in my
family too it was you know it was just a
different time you know did he joke with
you guys or was he always seriously
hilarious okay so my father was very
funny
um he could get hot very fast
um so but again it was a different time
you know I wasn't trashed I wasn't
talking back to my father anyway you
know I mean the way our kids are today
you know the the upside is they feel a
safety and a security around me where
they can say whatever it is
um about me and not worry about it when
you say hot would he ever hit you
um no he would get upset okay about what
it was this picture right here is that
your brother all the way to the right
yeah he's not gonna like this that's he
looks like I mean he looks like a guy
like a Sopranos character right there
and that's you by the way so I'm I am as
my mother used to say uh now she's 90
you know something although I don't know
why she's sensitive about that I was
like once you're 90 why do you want
people not to know you really anyway
um she's in her 90s and now she just
says oh yeah it was a complete surprise
she used to say I was a blessing back in
the day I'm 16 years from my oldest
sibling 13 from Andrew
um and you're look you're what three
years old in that picture I am probably
like eight or something seven eight and
I'm much younger than my other siblings
Andrew is like a father to me which is
another important thing to understand
about my level of dedication
um loyalty yeah he is you know
especially uh with pop gone I never
looked outside my own family for a male
role model so
you know
uh you know you know my whatever it is
that I know and that I do
was either taught by
or figured out in reaction to what I saw
in those two guys
um so the idea of
any kind of subjective process as to
whether or not I'm there for them
misunderstands the nature of my family
and my upbringing you know so let's go
to that let's go to that with you know
uh
well you're saying while you're working
at you know the pressure and then all of
a sudden I'm thinking I'm helping my
brother out but I failed actually didn't
end up helping him out I thought I was
doing good I done awesome I get fired
and I don't know what's going on so the
stories we read about you know that's
public you know behind closed doors he
was helping him with the uh you know
what to say and what not to say how to
handle the media but then you you know
knew what was going on here some of that
stuff went from the outside we see
and I think about if my my sons are
going through it I think we had this
debate in our uh a prep meeting
yesterday was it yesterday or Thursday I
don't know where to pray we're doing it
yesterday yeah and I said so let me get
this straight so if my my son doesn't
protect the other son they would have a
problem with me if you didn't back each
other up right so that part of it now
gamesmanship there's another thing where
if I know
Chris's brother is going through what
he's going through I'm not a fool to
know your loyalty is going to be to your
brother that's the loyalty to your
brother because in your mind you're like
my father's watching me right now you
better XYZ K so that's that part then
the other part is
as a person running CNN I can't set you
up for failure where you can't be
communicating with certain people so I
have to have a clear set of meetings to
say guys if you do this you're also
going to get fired so don't set him up
for failure where he can get in trouble
but you also can't do anything because
you could get fired so this is my Optics
from the outside I don't know what
happened on the inside if you want to
kind of walk us through how some of this
stuff take place what they said and what
you said and maybe we'll go from there
well look as you guys know I'm in the
middle of an arbitration process I know
with 125 million all that yeah and I
don't want them look it's not about the
money okay it really isn't there's no
question I was damaged by the situation
uh I am not going to give anybody the
opportunity to say that I was trying to
Prejudice that process but I will say
this
um
there was complete transparency and
understanding of everything that was
going on because it was all obvious
the only thing I take exception to is
the idea that I was acting in bad faith
or that I was lying or anything like
that I told the audience
I'm helping my brother
um I'm not reporting on my brother if
they had asked me to not be on air I
wouldn't have been on air I offered they
CNN yeah I offered twice to resign when
things started to get hot I was like I
don't want to hurt you guys I didn't
know you know the reason I apologized if
you listen to my apology wasn't I
shouldn't helped my brother it was hey
if what I was doing compromised you guys
and your ability to do what you do I'm
sorry I never meant for that to happen
and I didn't see it happening because it
seemed pretty obvious that you know CNN
isn't helping you know is isn't what
we're talking about here it's Chris
Cuomo who told the audience
um I never went to journalists and tried
to manipulate their coverage of my
brother or use my contacts and I think
the best evidence of that is where are
they what do you think they're
protecting me this is the same people
who have gone out of their way to say as
much negative things as they could they
they're not going to stand up and say
yes you did you called me that they
wouldn't do that come on and the idea of
you know well you were going after his
accusers no I was saying you can't now
way I understand why some people
criticize and say hey that was bad
advice you gave your brother he didn't
he didn't fight back enough he should
have fought back maybe you're right
maybe you're wrong but the idea that I
was some master of the dark arts
ask the people involved so I if they had
said you you can't be on TV it wouldn't
have been on TV they're my boss not me
if they had said you can't interview
your brother I I wouldn't have I didn't
want to in the first place you know they
that was something that they just
thought was worth
um whatever risk there was with it but I
don't I don't want to jaundice the case
I I want this to be settled fairly it's
not about the money
I never lied I didn't act in bad faith I
didn't manipulate media for my brother I
didn't go after his accusers I didn't
suggest he go after uh them in any way
other than just by trying to say what
his side of the story was and say it
early and say it often
um and it's just all terrible uh what
happened to him uh
was terrible and painful for a lot of
different people for a lot of different
reasons
um you know it took time for me to sink
in exactly how big a hit I had taken
I'll never get that back
I love being at news Nation I love
building something I have so much
loyalty and appreciation for them giving
me an opportunity I'm very glad that
it's going well and there's been great
acceptance by the audience as it grows
um but I was the number one show on the
number one platform in the world I was
relevant if not resonant on everything
that was happening in the dialogue in
this country and just like that it was
gone
and it was gone on the basis of things
that were already known
that's what was boggling my mind I was
like wait I don't understand what do you
mean there was more going on I was
helping my brother I was listening to
his team about what they wanted to do
they were running things by me I was
giving them my take they almost always
didn't take my advice and maybe they
were right maybe they were wrong but I
was that that's what it was and
everybody knew it and I told it to the
audience that's the part that boggled my
mind and that all of a sudden you know
people that I I knew and I I trusted and
I thought everything changed so look I
don't talk about it on the show other
than what I've just said which is to
keep it General because I'll deal with
it there it's not your concern it's not
about the audience this is about me and
my former bosses and I'll leave it at
that I'll never trash CNN I have
tremendous respect for the outlet and
the people there I think they do great
work I have tremendous respect for my
boss
Jeff Zucker
I he and I do not agree about what
happened here he is the best mind of
Television I've ever been around he gave
me tremendous opportunities that allowed
me to be who I became at CNN I cannot
take that away from him
um have you guys had any interaction
dinner since you left no if you had to
go back again would you have Andrew
Andrew on or you would that have been
something you would have changed here's
I here's really the best answer
I would do it again and I'll tell you
why is it an obvious do you fail the
journalism conflict of course
but you know conflicts can be cured by
transparency okay
I don't believe anyone in the audience
was ever deceived into thinking I was
giving my brother a pass
journalistically I don't believe that
I've never heard that from someone who
doesn't work in the media
um I think it helped people I I think it
comforted people I think it gave them a
sense of normalcy and relatability in a
time that was completely unnatural
and frightening and if it helped people
even though I knew I was going to pay a
price I just didn't think it was that
price I just think there would be I
thought there was just going to be a
series of Articles saying how
I shouldn't have done it uh you know and
I even said you know if you go back and
look I even said on TV
there's going to come a time when this
has to end because there will be a
period of accountability there always is
Right mistakes are going to be made
and I can't interview my brother about
the mistakes because I'm not objective I
said it on TV and people always got it
yeah so for that part if I could do it
again how could I not do something that
I know was of tremendous value to the
audience Chris I got to tell you when I
moved to Dallas from Miami to Dallas
right during covid to work with pbd
amazing opportunity valuetainment we
started the pbd podcast with zero
subscribers and it was at the height of
kovid
and I can't tell you I mean Peabody
started the entire podcast off with hey
look I'm a fan I like what you did we
would watch you and your brother
and this guy right here who just said at
the beginning listen we might not agree
politically on some issues
love these guys man to watch these guys
go at it it's so awesome it's so Raw
it's so real
and it's interesting how it worked out
so there's a there's a saying that
people say oh he's a real one man that
guy's a real one dude he's a real guy
right there's even a podcast uh John
Bernthal real ones right
you know you seem and and you you give
off just you're just like a dude you're
just a sharp smart real guy you talked
about Trump earlier and then your mom
went to the same beauty parlor as his
mom you grew up with him so as someone
that's so real and so wrong so truthful
and now Trump labels you and all your
people that essentially have defended as
fake news the fake news how do you
process something like that
uh
professionally
it's a good tactic
it's good tactic playing on people's
misgivings about the media you know you
said something earlier when did this
start yeah always
if you go back and read about the
Lincoln Douglas debates that was some
ugly stuff there were suggestions of
sexuality there was it was ugly and you
know there wasn't even any media the
thing that has changed for better and
worse and I my needle goes a little bit
uh in the negative direction is more
magnification okay there's so much more
media there's so much more ability for
platform and again I'm in favor of more
speech not less I'm very concerned uh by
what some are seeing as censorship
that's a very heavy word for me but I
believe in more ideas not less ideas
beat the idea with a better idea test
the idea just do it the right way but we
have so many outlets now
that can seem as significant as this one
like you know any podcast can seem until
you do the research and see the reach
the link looks the same as the pbd
podcast you know it must be the same
even though it's some Bag of Donuts you
know sitting around with no basis of no
intelligence or any of the things you
guys bring to bear
and in that way we've magnified Fringe
voices so you now see your two political
parties
and full disclosure and I know
journalists don't say this very often
the two-party system is a game that is
killing us
um and our leaders have said it from the
beginning the results have shown up from
the beginning the two-party system is
toxic
it is a battle to the bottom and it is
zero-sum and it is not what our system
was set up to be it is not an animal of
our constitution or any of the formative
documents it's not even a creature of
law it's culture and they should not be
in control and the Democrats are upset
about a potential third party bid right
now the blame is on them
uh if you do not give people the best
choice how can you criticize their
desire their desire for more Choice oh
but it's existential it can't be Trump
that's on you and the process has put us
in this position and I'm against it I
want people to be free agents
the critical thinkers and be independent
and that's the plurality of this country
it's the fastest growing partisan
denomination which is nonpartisan so
that's what's changed is the more Factor
okay you have Fringe ideas that get
magnified so much so that in a reductive
process a battle of attrition a battle
to the bottom Zero Sum I must lose for
you to win
both parties are dominated by the French
elements
and people like you guys sit around and
say like I don't get it I run a business
I run I do this where's the
accommodation why would I work with you
when it is easier for me to just
demonize you why would I do the work why
would I talk about how the chip factory
in Arizona is going to bring in
Taiwanese labor because we don't have
enough skilled laborers here in this
country why would I take that on when I
can say
um you know you want my kid to be gender
fluid
well I mean one is so much easier plays
to people's fears and Prejudice and
concerns culture wars are almost
entirely [__] because they fly in
the face of the Bedrock principle of
this country is you do you and I'll do
me okay you ever hear the expression
your ability to throw a punch ends where
my nose begins you know what I mean and
we've gotten way away from that hmm
for good reason and bad reason you know
it's hard to argue do you want a guy who
looks like him running against your 15
year old daughter in a race or in a
wrestling match no
but is that really happening enough
where we have to make it higher on the
agenda then what the right move is and
for how long and in what way in Ukraine
the only reason you would you would
never do that with one of your companies
you would never do that with one of your
companies because your bottom line would
suffer you'd never grow you'd you would
fail at the first of your five move
analysis you would be failing to know
yourself and understand yourself so
that's the problem my problem is I can't
effectively combat the problem it's
suffused in our culture we cover the
game
these UFO hearings okay people are
making fun of us at news Nation they
completely misunderstand the import
I don't know if they're little green men
I choose to believe there is a higher
intelligence that is actually paying
attention to what's happening here right
now
and that he sent his son here to
literally die for the sins of people
like me because I'm so flawed and so
weak and that is the basis of my faith
that's why you never hear me proselytize
put it on anybody I don't care what you
believe
as long as it's not actively hurting
somebody else
I need it because I'm so flawed and I'm
so desperate for any way I can use to
get better but I choose to believe that
but I'm going to be close to the idea
that there's life beyond this planet
this is the only one that figured out
when Neil deGrasse Tyson tells me every
five minutes that the place is bigger
every time we measure it no I'm open but
that's not what the hearings are about
UFO for me stands for unable to find out
why the F does the government get to
make unilateral decisions about what we
get to know and not so that now you're
gonna have a congressional hearing and
NASA gets to say I'm not coming
and the Pentagon gets to say to its
people you better stay here who what
where where is that how is that okay
they should have to come and account to
the American people or at least the
Congress and say why you don't get to
know what they know and if it's because
it will lead to a huge competitive
disadvantage with China okay put some
meat on the bones for me the Kennedy
assassination files
why why can't you release them I'll tell
you why because each Administration some
guy comes to them
and says
you're new
so you're probably a little intimidated
by me right now let me seize upon that
to tell you this you do not want to
release these files you will have a
problem that you will own sources and
methods
things that people will know you think
that happens I think it happens every
Administration how else would you
explain of all guys Captain Chaos former
president Trump yeah
when he is a If he if a former president
has one kind of policy agenda it's I
want people to feel comfortable thinking
that the institutions of government are
not serving their interests so somebody
had the conversation with them and he
said I shouldn't release this
information today I think somebody had a
conversation with somebody who had a
conversation with him I don't I I'm
probably who they protect him
themselves and a bit again look I don't
believe themselves I don't believe in
the Deep State I don't believe in any of
that okay it's it's much more nuanced
than that you sound like that by the way
your last five minutes you sound like an
anti-establishment guy though which you
just said that five minute clip I just
think that label is cheap look nobody
gets the benefit of context right you
can cut everything up any way you want
you can make me seem anything I would
trust you more by the way I'm not I'm
don't take that as a shot what I'm
saying to you is be an
anti-establishment I'm not
anti-establishment journalists question
power I never defended the FBI one day
in my life before the Trump
administration because there became this
threat to the institution overall I
don't like I hate the I can neither
confirm nor deny I hate that answer
either you're trying to make a case
against pbd or you're not just give the
answer I've been chasing after the FBI
for 20 years
that doesn't mean I don't think they
should exist you know what I mean I
don't want the IRS looking into me any
more than they need to either it's not
that I don't think they should exist so
I was I felt forced into that position
because of this power being brought to
undo a system with no better solution
after that so I'm not anti-establishment
my job look to your ears but to me it's
I test power
um the the dossier okay uh the dossier
has become a buzzword what is a dossier
it's a French word for file this was raw
intelligence from a single guy who was
working a situation for hire for a
pocket that was connected to Clinton
they should have told us that right away
they did say it was raw the entire
investigation was not all based on the
dossier but but and I say this all the
time and I know why people get upset
you can't have politicians investigating
their opposition you can't do it and you
can say Mueller but we had Mueller do it
it doesn't work
and it is a complete distraction from
our interests the hunter Biden stuff the
Trump stuff
look you break a law and you can prove
it make the case make the case but I'm
telling you these investigations that
reek of politics are destroying us
they're destroying us do I like the
payments to the different members of the
bidens nope do I like that they haven't
been out in front of it and explaining
it nope
uh I understand the adage that if you're
explaining you're losing in politics but
let me tell you something if you don't
tell me your story somebody else is and
you're not going to like the ending so I
don't like those things do I want them
to be the sum total of our existence no
I don't feel like that about the
classified documents I didn't feel like
that about the impeachment things I was
on the record saying one don't talk
about you may impeach impeach or don't
impeach but don't play with it and once
they went down the road of impeachment I
said why are you doing this you'll never
remove them
well they told them that I said it on TV
all the time the historicity of it no
one is above the law first of all that's
not true okay yes no one is above the
law
no one is above the law okay
conceptually but there is prosecutorial
discretion okay and that's why you don't
find a lot of tax cases like the one
they're even making against Hunter Biden
oh but it was 17 million how many people
do you know who have gotten sideways
with the IRS in the millions of dollars
and went to prison
it's very very rare they find the hell
out of you if you fight it you wind up
in a civil judgment situation but you're
probably going to lose okay and then
they're more fines but they're going to
jail the criminal I mean just look at it
the numbers are very small
so but I don't want you to go to jail
they want the payment plan that's right
but it's all but I'm just saying
people know so much more about this than
things that actually matter
and I cover those things more than what
actually matters why ratings resonance
people don't care about these other
things because culturally we're into
this fight of what makes one side go
down and one what makes one side go up
which is at the cost of the other side
all the time so Biden is the best choice
why okay we're better than Trump
you don't make that analysis anywhere
else in your life I'm going to buy a
Hugo
or I'm gonna buy a Fiat
well I guess I'm going with the Fiat why
he was you go no I want to drive what
he's driving why because that's the best
not the least worst that's what we've
allowed in our politics to get there
uh and
it kills me because I'm not I'm not able
to correct it that's why I do the free
agent stuff
you know that that's why I'm selling
merch with free agent on it I haven't
taken a dime of it I want the kitty to
get big and then I want to crowdsource
contributions with it I'm not making
money off it I'm not making money off
any of this [__] I'm making half what I
used to make you know those days are
over that was taken from me so I have to
go in in a different direction and I'm
figuring that out as I go but I do know
the challenge the challenge is the
system
the two-party system is killing us
primaries should be open ranked Choice
voting should be considered and figured
out
voting should be streamlined and
understood and transparent we've got to
be able to do better than this all my
money I don't even know where it is I
don't even know what it is all my
information is online I paid my uh my um
my my mortgage my maintenance payment
and a couple utility bills on my phone
on the way over here
but we can't we can't figure out a way
to automate voting so that we know who
people are you know that wouldn't favor
Democrats if they did that look I
understand the argument that there are
there is an imbalance
of enfranchisement as you go down the
socioeconomic scale so and again
sometimes it's not the better political
argument the better political argument
is show your ID when you vote it's it's
a no-brainer political argument until
you get into the weeds of What kinds of
people tend to not have driver's
licenses what kinds of people tend to be
less likely to want to have a government
ID and you get into socioeconomic levels
they do play to Democrats I get that but
that goes back to you know when you said
you know the the trans thing do I want a
guy this uh Pat's size to compete
against my you know 11 year old daughter
and says it's trans no but is that
really the top 10 issues in America no
that's a small little thing right what
you just said right now is a very very
small percentage of Americans that don't
have an ID but the other side will then
use it and will say well that's why
Republicans are racist no it's just
let's get an ID if we have the
technology right now with crypto where
you and I if I'm going to like you know
November uh 2001 what came out in
November of 2001 something called TSA
okay and why was TSA you know prior to
that you go to the airport you know what
would happen he's just going hey hey
what's I'll come to the gate see me at
the gate okay I'll come to the I don't
need to go through security 911 happens
TSA give me your ID now what do they do
when you give the ID they put it in
there you don't even need to see your uh
what do you call it the the boarding
space yeah that's okay what's your ID
okay you're good all right so if we have
that technology there do you realize how
ludicrous and how dumb it sounds to say
it's racist to ask for my ID go back to
what you said why I said you sound
anti-establishment so your your your dad
would you say your dad was
would you say your dad was an
anti-establishment uh candidate or what
would you say your pops was I don't like
the term anti-establishment and I'll
tell you why because I think that there
is currency but I think that it is
reductive I think that it takes us in
the wrong direction of wanting to be
anti so you do that can you can you can
you define what establishment means to
you to me
anti-establishment is code for tear it
down uh destroy the government get rid
of everything everybody's dirty
everything's corrupt everyone cheats
there is no justice and I don't believe
that I believe that you have problems in
all of these things but I don't need to
say this
um uh to you or really any of you guys
but I mean you know it's just so it's
just so
intimate for his family's you know last
two generations of experience go live
somewhere else and see if you think that
our justice system sucks that you know
our imbalances here are unforgivable if
our government is so dirty go live
somewhere else and see uh how how well
oh well you go to Sweden yeah okay go to
Sweden
um you know so I'm worried about being
just negative to feed some sense of
demagoguery do I think that all of these
different things have buckets of concern
that should be addressed absolutely
absolutely I just don't think we get
there by just seeing who can [__] on it
more my father described his Politics as
Progressive pragmatism which is you go
you have a set of principles and you go
Case by case now In fairness to the
analysis he was a lefty okay he was a
new first generation immigrant in this
country who believed in helping the Have
Nots he believed that guys like you and
guys like me should shut up and pay
because we got to help these people so
that we can have more people like you
and more people like me
he believed in speaking for the people
who are the underclass he was a true
anti-elitist when I got into Yale
my father was so upset
he was like really that's where you want
to go with them he was and us and them
guys the I finished first in college
they made me split it with the Irish guy
I finished first in law school they made
me finish it was uh split it with the
Irish guy I couldn't get a job on Wall
Street I had to work in Brooklyn they
called me the swore the ethnic the gap
tooth grin the circles under my eyes
Mercurial Mario
and now you want to go with them with
the biffs he said why because they had
put him down his whole life one of the
last jokes my father told me rest in
peace and the pain is fresh because Tony
Bennett one of his remaining uh close
friends just passed and
he was reading something about me and
where I was in white privilege and he
went
hot damn we made it Christopher's white
privilege because you know the joke was
he wasn't treated that way he was still
considered an ethnic you know and now
with assimilation and everything you
know now Italian Americans basically
just more white people here depending on
how they want to keep their own
Traditions
um so that's why I'm shy about being
anti
anything and it's not just a semantic
thing for me but I'm absolutely anti the
two-party system
I'm absolutely anti uh the parties being
in charge of the primary process in the
states I think it's a huge mistake I
think it's tearing us apart and that's
why thank God for the American people
seeing it and wanting to be independent
more than they want to be anything
here's what I've taken away from you
okay so far and we got obviously a lot
more things to go through I've taken
that indirectly you're not a fan of Joe
Biden you don't think he's the best
candidate indirectly that's my
interpretation because what you said I'm
not a fan of Joe Biden it's not a
personal thing I just think that it is
there are better candidates out there
than him well I think the fact that we
don't have more better robots look the
fact that there aren't more guys with
your kind of background
and there's a group out now that's
trying to get more veterans into
leadership positions in communities and
using those skills and get them into
politics
I think we can do better than the people
that we have in the ruling class right
now and I don't mean class us them
I get why guys like you would want to
stay away from it I get that the level
of scrutiny and stuff like that is
absurd uh it's like almost it's just
it's not about if it's about when they
find something that you know you can't
explain to everybody else's satisfaction
I think we can do better it's not a
knock on him uh look Joe Biden is not
Beau Biden okay may he rest in peace
Beau Biden would have checked a lot of
boxes for guys like you
um and I just think we can do better in
this country but we have a system that
discourages people from getting involved
and so I'm not I'm not ant I'm that's
not the kind of guy I am but that's but
what I was saying is you didn't come
here to support Joe Biden you know Joe
Biden's the greatest you didn't do that
so number two Democrat number two you
were not a Democrat no I'm not a dentist
even though your father was a Democrat
is Cuomo I'll vote for you you can be a
giraffe party I'm going to vote for you
you're my you know I mean that's that's
what what I am first of all this isn't
my father's party
this this is not my father's party this
is not Reagan's party
um I agree I fully agree so that's
that's what we're on the so what would
you say you are you're a registered
independent or just a republican yeah I
Look it's even gotten hard for me to
vote you know you show up at the place
to vote everybody's like talking to you
looking at you you know
um it's become uh difficult for me
I don't do part I am anti-party if you
want to if that prefix on something they
are a problem and then people will say
to me even you know the big brains and
people I respect yeah but Chris but
that's the system yeah but then what
changes if nothing changes nothing
changes you know if I say to you Hey
listen you got to cut out the Diet Cokes
man you know it's it's spike in your
glycemic index even though you guys are
yeah yeah but you know that's what I
drink yeah I know but if what we're
trying to do is get your blood sugar
down we got to get rid of this [__]
that's what we have to do yeah but you
can't you can't change the party not now
at least not now right now it matters
too much when does it not matter when
have we ever had an election cycle where
I didn't say
uh where I didn't hear someone say
because I won't say it this is probably
the most important election of our time
you know it's like that every freaking
time so when is something going to
change people wonder how Trump uh became
popular I saw it the first rally I went
to uh you know where we were covering it
and I was like oh yeah I saw that he was
an agent
for legitimate grievance you can argue
with him as the appropriate agent that's
fine yeah that's politics but the
mistake I believe the media made in a
lot of people on the left made was
discounting the people's feelings
of disaffection of
um social engineering of uh imbalanced
uh workplace of a sliding values scale
of fears for their kids and the ability
to uh succeed those are real fears a
mistrust of government that now there
are ruling classes political classes
those are all real So when you say
you're stupid to support Trump
you're saying that you you don't believe
that I have legitimate reasons to feel
the way I do you're telling me I'm wrong
to feel the way I do
that is not only dangerous politically
uh that is bad psychology and bad human
interaction
and I understand that that's what Trump
is for people I understand that that's
why there's such forgiveness for his
obvious shortcomings as a candidate
because in their minds yes yes but this
is also true about all these other guys
you just don't go after them the same
way now I happen to not agree with that
but that doesn't matter the analysis
stays the same
which is
he is a guy with a lot of money who they
believe can't be compromised by what
compromises everybody else which is
money true or not uh he knows the system
he's worked the system okay and he's got
tremendous cachet as a celebrity which
we discounted how much celebrities
matter in this country uh and he hates
who they fear
and worry about and he hates them and
that is very powerful and that's why
DeSantis can't get the same traction
on paper
strong strong but he's trying to play
Trump's game but he's not Trump
he's not Trump he's an inside guy and
you are not going to check the same
boxes the same way and also the sequel
is Never As Good As you know as the
first movie you know other than the
Godfather
yeah I guess although you know the
reason that the second one and even the
third one built the way it did is
because what was set with that first one
but of course you can't have a second if
you don't have a first so it's not a
fair fair analysis but you're right most
people agree with you it's a platform
building you know you talked about the
system and what's very interesting to me
that I've been watching over the last
year is the is the phrase unit party and
there are disaffected people that are on
both sides you're not and you know what
I'm talking about let's say it's such a
rigged uniparty game it's really a
uniparty and it's rigged there's little
differences on both sides and I'm going
to say a name here but I'm not picking
on one party but Nancy Pelosi made a
comment when w was President listen we
only have to manage him for eight years
and I sat back and I thought on that and
in that statement by the way I think
that statement gets made on both sides
of the aisle quite a bit where they're
really looking at hey the game is US
Congress we're going to be here forever
I said but we just have to manage this
cap for eight years and I sat back and I
said that's terrible you know that is
just that that you know this most
wonderful system of government that we
had it's basically you have found a way
to [__] it both sides and then you
hear about the the uniparty side and the
comments that are making on that you
sound like
you you sound like you're very carefully
articulated but it sounds like you're
kind of feeling that down the middle as
well look you have you know I don't like
the word middle because middle is always
weak you never want to be in the middle
of anything right if you're in the
middle of anything that happens you're
gonna get punched in the face in that
there is reasonable there is left and
right and then there is the rest of your
life okay how you get along with your
neighbors how you deal with your kids
education uh how you deal with conflicts
at work uh and within your own business
and in your own relationships and
friendships we don't behave the way we
behave in our politics anywhere else I
guarantee each of you guys and everybody
here has someone in their life whom they
love the family they choose that they
have a huge disagreement with about
something
could be anything it could be the type
of tackle you use when you go to a
certain place or where you and where
you're like this is just the dumbest
thing I would never do what you do I
can't believe you did this with your
house with your business what you allow
with your kids whatever it is but I love
you and we we are we have so much more
that holds us together than this
the only place where we don't allow that
to predominate is politics right and why
because it works better
because you only have two choices and if
you can make one seem more scary than
the other that's enough but that doesn't
work anywhere else in our life what I'm
saying is there's such a big space of uh
common concern and understanding and
shared belief
that we are harping on left and right
who necessarily want to keep us apart
because that's how they keep advantage
the answer to the Pelosi's premise is
very simple term limits yep term limits
but you can't get them why you most
likely need a constitutional amendment
and I don't think we could get a
constitutional amendment on the name of
this country being America
other than some people who believe it
had nothing to do with Amerigo Vespucci
okay you can believe that but I'm of the
school that it did you don't think if we
dig into that cat enough or we're going
to find things about him that we don't
like in today's set of mores and that
you're not going to have a bunch of blue
States who get enough energy to say now
we can't we can't name it America so I
don't think we can get a constitutional
amendment on anything for good reason or
bad reason
so you're not going to have that
um you're not going to have that happen
but that's very very sad to me because
you can't be in there forever
um that's never what it was supposed to
be you know on this topic that we're on
uh so you're not here promoting Joe
Biden as the goat you're not for
censorship you want to know what the
hell happened with JFK I know what
happened with JFK I want you to be able
to know and judge it for yourself and
first of all everybody who could be
really hurt by what's in there is dead
right I mean we're talking about
something that happened 60 years ago
um plus 60 plus years ago but you know
what happened to JFK look you can Google
it right now and you'll see that there
are huge holes in the idea of single
shooter and look I'm not happy to have
this be an analysis of the mob right
because that is the stain on my people
uh and I hate I hate the mob uh you know
you ask people now we're getting a
little old but you ask people why Mario
Cuomo didn't run for governor and I bet
you one in four of them I'm sorry
president is going to say uh something
to do with the mafia yeah
um George H.W bush May rest in peace
said to my father at a dinner one night
you know we had an FBI file uh open on
you about uh Mafia associations we never
really found anything and my father
always Muse that he was like surprised
by he sounded surprised when he said it
to my Father which is of course he I I
doubt my father didn't think he meant it
to be insulting at all he thought he was
a very gentle man but just imagine if
like somebody said yeah you know pbd you
know the whole bet David thing you know
House of David we started looking to see
if you had I didn't find anything in
that weird you'd be like well you mean
he didn't find it you know put respect
over here so yeah the link too you know
so I don't like that but if you look
it's all over the place can you just
clarify you sound very convinced what do
you actually think happened with JFK I
believe that there is or clearly he was
assassinated but the idea of it was just
Lee Harvey Oswald who was just some
whack job nobody believes the single
shooter thing so you know
but so then why can't we know so let's
say we're wrong let's say it is exactly
that it's Lee Harvey Oswald the single
shooter everything else is [__]
propaganda for some agenda of of uh
disassociative thinking okay
show me well I can't prove the
non-existence of effect yes you can you
can tell me why you know it was just him
you can tell me why the FBI the CIA
nobody around uh who was supposed to be
in the business of protecting the
president had any reason to worry about
anything
because we know that wasn't true about 9
11 and not that there was a bunch of
Israelis dancing around happy about 9
11. that is ugly fake talk but why did
we change everything after 9 11 because
we knew we could do better why don't
they want to release these files because
it's going to show that there was
compromise around the president of the
United States in terms of what was known
what was suspected and what was done
and they don't want to make themselves
look bad and I get that I can't date him
in the FBI and the CIA yeah and then
just you know those those people
establishments those people the people
in the intelligence business sources and
methods look I don't have to tell you of
course you have to protect that
but the idea that look when you
trust is based on transparency and when
you don't tell me things
you are begging me to come up with
another solution right it's the root of
all conspiracies yeah you know if you're
not going to tell me that's why I love
when Trump plays with the anonymous
sources there's no question I'll tell
you I haven't done this for a long time
if we didn't have Anonymous sources you
would know nothing
because people are afraid of what it's
going to cost them I want to give you
this information but I want to lose my
job you know over it oh there's
whistleblower protection yeah great show
me a successful whistleblower you know
so you need Anonymous sources but you
just need to trust the outlets and make
sure that they're doing the rigorous
work that goes along with it but then he
wants to use anonymous sources when they
work for him because you know that's how
it works both ways and he's not the only
one to do that of course but release it
let people decide for themselves what do
you think do you think it's LBJ do you
think it's CIA do you think it I haven't
seen the files but in the discussions
that I've had with people who know a lot
more than I do
um it's just more complicated than that
and there was mob involvement
and that's embarrassing look I don't
have energy I don't have [__] to do with
the mob you know just because I'm an
Italian-American but it is embarrassing
to me I don't like that the largest
cultural understanding of my ethnicity
is these scumbags but
um look the truth is the truth
and it helps to know and I'll tell you
why it's healing
it's healing when you say I screwed up
but we screwed up here we shouldn't do
it this way anymore so we changed after
this it gives people a reason to believe
it gives people reason now why don't we
do it I'll tell you why we don't do it
and I'll tell you why
I understand why people don't want to
apologize in normal life okay
you were supposed to show up last night
you didn't you know I needed you there
would have meant something to me you had
a good reason bad reason no reason
your relationship with me matters you're
going to apologize and I'm going to say
all right I get it or maybe I don't get
it but I I love you thank you I I
believe you're not going to do it again
that's how relationships work okay it is
not how politics in the media works if
you apologize you are weak and I will
beat you over the head with the apology
and I will probably use it to extend
your exposure
so you can apologize you can't say you
did things wrong nobody gives you the
benefit forever
there comes so so so again you're not
supporting Jay Joe Biden censorship JFK
uh uh two vote you know party system
military running for office all this
stuff this is all a message of somebody
who is
anti-establishment because if somebody
in the last three years were to say
where the left is the one that's
censored God knows I can't tell you how
many of my clips from RFK were taking
down I can't tell you how many of my
videos that we did during covet got you
know strikes and then later on they're
like well now you can talk about it
that's not the right that was doing it
during this period JFK fine I mean
that's both left and right that are
hiding you Trump could have brought it
out it's not just the left and when it
comes on to JFK voting the left doesn't
want that to happen with the you know
side and by the way if you can pull up
the chart right now that the uh the
trust in the government so this is
public trust in the US government from
58 to 22. we know when it drops in the
60s if you see right when it's at the
peak 76 77 boom LBJ brings it all the
way down then we come up a little bit
and we go all the way down again then we
come up a little bit then we go all the
way now this is the lowest it's ever
been the American people this right here
says I don't trust
but you have so much more media
uh attacking trust look I don't even I
don't I mean there's a lot more
negativity in the uh space of
information now than we've ever had
before and look I don't know a lot of
things that's causing it you think
absolutely I look people have always had
low levels of trust uh ever since you
got into the 60s uh in the trust no one
over 30 in the war and they started to
know about the the reality that the
government can push for situations that
are disingenuous and that became known
and understood culturally and it's been
you know up and down but on a downward
tread even pre go back to the number Rob
but you're a guy go back to the uh yeah
even pre-social this is down I mean
social you can say whatever I mean that
started really happening since the 60s
you know since the 60s you're going to
see attrition and you're going to see
certain things that change that to you
know 9 11. obvious basically changed it
until it didn't right and now it's going
to keep trending down but now we have a
lot more energy
invested in negativity than we do of
anything reasonable or positive
I mean that's how you make money today
you want to get involved in the media
you got to be joining some kind of hate
parade or an agenda of some kind of
Discord and that's where you're going to
make your money uh you know you know I
know one guy who's doing well in social
media
um uh being a pure positive it's that MD
motivator guy who goes or you know the
guy who is standing outside and say hug
me if you've ever been depressed or he
goes up to people and be like oh I I
forgot my wallet can you give me a
couple bucks to get gas or something and
when the Lady or the guy gives it to
them he's like here's a thousand bucks
yeah thank you forever they cry yeah you
know he's like the only guy who I know
who's spiking that way everything else
is playing to a conspiracy or a
reductive agenda and not that it's
untrue
um but it's certainly more often than
not unhelpful uh so I'm I understand why
that's going down you'd see a similar
Trend with media you'd see a similar
Trend with religion you'd see a similar
Trend with corporate
um you know brand trust and Goodwill
we're in a reductive period did and my
concern is well how do you address it
and what can you do about it my biggest
concern is
the only thing that I see getting us to
a better place
is catastrophe
and the pandemic didn't work the 911
worked for a little bit
uh but even that I didn't like because
it made people come together
in unified fear and hatred toward a
group that we then blew out of
proportion
again I get why people were frustrated
with Obama not wanting to say Islamic
Terror
it would make sense given that you got a
billion Muslims that you don't want to
throw them all in the same bucket
I get why Trump's early Salvo was Islam
hates us
and then he said but I got a lot of
Muslim friends who I love you know
um Muslim
I get it I get that it works but that
doesn't make it right and I get that you
may have a right to say something but it
doesn't make it right that we've gotten
confused
um and I know people beat me up about
this all the time
uh de-platforming no that's censoring
but don't have people on who are just
there to lie let the audience decide how
to judge the lies don't put me in the
position of saying I'm not going to have
somebody on because I think they have no
value unless you're talking about
somebody who is in rarefied air you do
not get to come on to any platform I
control and talk about anti-Semitism or
about how One race is better than
another race you know you do not have a
hood on and come on my show why zero
value of making anything better well
that's a subjective judgment yeah it is
but we're talking about an extreme
category you want to come on and talk
about the vaccine let's talk about the
vaccine you want to come on and talk
about covet what was done right what was
wrong you want to come and talk about
the Wuhan lab I want to know where the
pandemic started come on now but that
was not a conversation that was allowed
it was one of our it was one of our
first conversations and then we got
confused with the whole China Good China
bad right during the Trump
Administration right China was good
China's been great they've been so
extraordinary and cooperative and then
all of a sudden covet started to become
a problem for Trump blamed it on China
now China bad where did it come where
did it start from China I don't know if
you can say that but he was a guy that
was putting tariffs on those guys left
and right and uh he was doing a
negotiation side where he had that was
on the trade side two things can be true
at once people didn't get that but let
me tell you Chris if you're putting
tariffs on what what's shittier than a
terror you want to do this Huawei his
daughter's in Canada you're doing stuff
with Iran no problem here's another
tariff here's another tariff here's
another hey Mexico here's another tariff
he wasn't being the friendliest guy that
he was I'm saying he was with the
pandemic look I mean you know you call
the China virus they kept saying you
can't say China type in Trump China
Cooperative covet and you'll see it come
up that you know whatever the right
search phrase is that in the beginning
he was saying they've been great with us
right yeah 15 times praise China now
again I'm not blaming him see blaming is
cheap and easy it's not my point it was
a fluid Dynamic situation that we had
never handled before and for all the
misgivings about the vaccine
our outcomes are better because of
vaccine versus places that didn't have
it and we would have not gotten it if he
hadn't made it happen the way he did
which I thought was without question
the most unassailable Judgment of
leadership he made during his term which
was look I know there are a lot of
Hang-Ups and getting this done
get it done I'm telling you get it done
yeah and it's going to hurt him with
Republicans Republicans are going to you
know the the vaccine you know Community
but look
look
they are weaponizing the vaccine
for good bad and no reason and that's
politics I just believe that there's a
hyperemphasis on it and there's so many
more mouthpieces now in digital media
able to Echo these messages
that it becomes more persuasive all I'm
saying is two things can be true at once
okay
he had tough trade policy he had guys
who were trying to nail it down they
were trying to the deal kind of fell
apart you know
um but and that wasn't really his his
fault he over promised a little bit but
that's politics that's politics I'm okay
with it
um but the lab thing in the beginning we
were like yeah and we had to back off
because China was being helpful we
needed it for PPE so we you know we went
soft on and then by the time we came
back to it there was too much at risk so
we still don't know where it started and
now they blame Tony fauci you know you
know it's wild listening to you
um now and and watching Tucker no longer
at Fox okay so you were number one at
CNN Tucker was number one and Tucker's
obviously right now crushing it on fire
you know he's doing what he's doing on
Twitter his show is uh growing
independently wants to raise a few you
know 100 million dollars with Neil Patel
to do what he's doing
um you sound
more reasonable now listening to you
and almost like the handcuffs and the
shackles are off
versus what it was listening to you
three years ago Tucker sounds more Freer
today where he's kind of like almost a
kid in a candy store I'm free I can say
whatever I want I'm no longer under the
you know and there's an element of that
no matter where you're working at
whether you're at CNN on Fox you guys
don't have to agree on political uh
ideology but you can still be like okay
I am Freer because when I'm when I'm
listening to you I'm like okay this guy
sounds reasonable and reasonable and
reasonable fair I don't have to agree
with that but reasonable but reasonable
but reason brother when covet happened
when 9 11 happened it was us against the
folks in the Middle East right and then
later on we realized there was no
weapons of mass destruction we're like
oh [__] what was that all about right
and this time Iran is the company so
while we should have been against the
administration back then with Bush This
Time Around
the media that the complete opposite
everybody I ask I said if there was no
cover does Trump get reelected 95
percent of people I ask in politics
they'll say Pat not even a question
Trump gets reelected these are people on
the left that said Trump's going to get
reelected so
but covet happens
it almost seems like there was a
conference called on Rob can you pull up
the video I don't know if you can pull
this up you know the criticism media
gets where everybody is using the same
line like if you go on YouTube just type
in media bias saying the same thing on
YouTube you'll see it I'm sure you've
seen this clip before where it's like
same talking point same talking point
yeah same talking point whatever if you
pull that up uh uh so so it almost
seemed like we had a shot at that that's
the one right there if you can play that
yeah we had a shot
uh is it this one or no no go to the
bottom one go to the bottom one right
there see if it's that one right there
yeah it almost seemed like there was a
conference call or Zoom well maybe
conference call would have been better
for tubing but there was a conference
call where you guys and they said from
the top hey it's this is our shot this
is Trump's fault this is not China's
fault this is Trump's fault and then
rather than saying where else would this
thing come from we don't know it came
from China you can't say that that you
know you can't say this you know we're
in Chinatown Nancy Pelosi going out
there and saying well look we this is
offensive you can't do this you can't do
that you can't do this rob you can't
even find us on Twitter it's a lot
easier if you just go find us on Twitter
you'll find us like a 30 second clip and
suddenly everybody's like no it's
irresponsible you should have closed
sooner you should have closed this and
you should have done that wait a minute
you were just in Chinatown saying don't
close now you're saying I should have
done this it's as if everybody teamed up
against this guy and then that caused
the American people some of them uh to
say look we United during 9 11 what are
we doing being divided here and then two
years later
we look in and say he was right about
China virus about coronavirus oh they
were right the New York Times comes out
this week talking about a third of the
coveted vets was an exaggeration by the
CDC nobody covers it so remember people
wait a minute well you should have taken
a vaccine with the kids no you shouldn't
have well because the experts are saying
this well because science is saying this
well because military 14 years if you
don't take the vaccine you got to come
out dude you've only had a few months to
test this thing out no you got to do it
so now all of that pendulum goes back to
saying listen say what you want you guys
are wrong about Russia you were wrong
about China you were wrong about covet
you were wrong about the vaccine you
were wrong about this stuff what are you
going to say now to this again now you
want to 37 indictments you want to do
all this other stuff to the guy so what
do you what what level for somebody that
was on this I don't expect to get the
you know um
you know a hundred percent on what you
would say to this but what do you say to
the people that said dude you guys all
teamed up against this guy and everybody
was like a sounding like a broken record
as Trump's fault that's Trump's fault
that's Trump's fault what do you say to
that
I have a different analysis
um there was no conference call there
was no group thing
uh I don't know
uh how many people had more access to
people making major decisions during the
pandemic than I did
um
and I was certainly never told what to
say or what not to say
Trump got what he asked for with the
media
you antagonized the media and call them
fake
and say a lot of things that are
demonstrably false you're going to get
the teeth he was antagonistic
these are all human beings they're going
to take it personally at some point and
they're going to come for you and look I
think that's true in my case in my
brother's case for sure
uh it was absolutely true in the
president's case the idea that people
were against saying China virus is
more complicated
um we know it started in China now what
made us sick was actually the virus
flying through Europe right the cases
that came into the U.S you had a few on
the west coast but it was really these
people coming in from Europe into New
York Etc making people sick here does
that mean it didn't start in China no it
means that that's not the only question
it's not the dispositive factor yes it
started in China but it went flying
through all of Europe also so it's not
as simple as just busting on China
um Trump had it both ways with China and
he used China to deflect
accountability for himself as president
of the United States I do not believe
that if there was no covid Trump wins
necessarily I think it's hard to say
that I think if Trump had just stuck
with his original take on covid you
don't think if there's no call that
Trump doesn't win I don't know because
there are too many things there are too
many things but if you're playing an
odds game and nothing else happens I
don't I don't listen Chris the guy had
economy was good everything is good too
much [__] happens that I didn't expect
for me to say I know what would have
happened okay
um you know is could you do I think
you're 100 wrong of course of course not
um was covet a problem for him
absolutely but if he had stuck with I'm
now a wartime president this is my War
I'm doing PVE like nobody's business I
can't believe there's only one place in
Maine that can make these swabs I'm
gonna make them that mentality
and brought the vaccine and right and
wrong which plays into my real
frustration about covet other than
people thinking I didn't have it is
here's the problem okay
Trump did this wrong Biden did this
wrong
no one in a white coat
should be doing political messaging for
America
fauci
any of the other white coats that they
had up there from time to time
should not have been talking directly to
America about where we are how we are
what we are what we're not
science
changes okay
science changes
scientists
change their opinions all the time on
the basis of information we believe you
get this by doing this clean everything
a million times oh turns out it's
aerosolized forget about this don't
worry about it remember what I said
about don't wear a mask you'll probably
make yourself sick because you're
touching no it's aerosolized you need
the masks in science makes perfect sense
when you God forbid you have somebody
who's sick in your family and they start
and they think oh we think it's
pneumonia oh turns out it's pleurisy you
don't say the hell is wrong with you I'm
going to a new doctor it's oh the so you
found new information changed it okay
that doesn't work in politics and
politics you change your position you're
losing you're weak you're a flip-flopper
that's why they stick with things even
when it doesn't make sense anymore I had
a very I remember a conversation I'll
never forget what Roger Ailes he's
thinking about hiring me he's beating me
over the head about what he called
pro-life and I called you know even back
then Reproductive Rights and I was like
I don't get it you're pro-life but
you're pro-death penalty so like once
you're out of the womb it's like all
bets are off
he changed uh why because it's logically
inconsistent that's very rare in
politics so what happened during the
pandemic was you had these people who
are changing information scientifically
but they were living in a political
environment where you can't do that so
they started to get quiet about things
when they should have been loud the
biggest example is when they went from
the
touch touch too aerosolized they did not
tell us the way they should have because
they didn't want to own a mistake
because they knew it would affect
people's trust and their credibility but
I argued at the time it'll be just the
opposite
you're not politicians
and every problem after that was about
guesswork at the best scenario in a new
situation that they had never handled
before
separation no separation when when not
when it was all
well we don't really know I don't I
don't I don't know I know that it's
better that if we're all sick we should
probably know too close to each other if
we don't want to spread it but how and
when and why and for how long those were
political determinations
that should have been all Trump or his
people all Biden or his people I don't
see any white coat you can tell me that
you based it off what they just told you
about this new thing okay but what are
you telling me I elected you I didn't
elect these people
and political things are going to be
held to political tests and standards
and we got the two mixed here so you'll
see tons of Clips oh they told you this
and then they told you that that's
because they're looking look it used to
be the World is Flat then it's round you
know it used to be that uh you know a
lot of Christians believe that the Earth
is like you know a fraction as old as it
really is and that Humanity's only a
fraction you know it depends what do you
want to base it off feel a fact
and that was the confusion that happened
during that
and I told Dr fauci personally and
publicly multiple times you got to get
yourself out of that position
Tony you do not belong making political
and he would say I'm not make a player
but that's how it's playing seems like
he loved that's how it's being used
I look I've known him most of my adult
life okay yeah he was close to my father
um and very helpful to my father during
the AIDS uh and look I'll tell you we
lived it then too oh it's a gay disease
this is what you get for being gay they
used to call AIDS and HIV grid because
they wanted to tie it to gay people and
Tony fauci was one of the early ones
saying this is not sexuality based it's
transmission based that is uh you know
fluid but also this right so
um so I know him Tony fauci's a good man
who does things for the right reason is
he fallible of course
um he felt that he was doing the right
thing and he had a lot of people in
power from two administrations trying to
push him to the front
because it was better for them he gave
them cover
and I don't believe that our leaders
should take cover when it's time to lead
and I think Biden did it wrong and I
think Trump did it wrong did you read
rfk's book on fouchy I did what'd you
think about it I think that he is not
giving the doctor the benefit of context
and Nuance when it comes to funding and
what was known and what was hidden
versus overlooked and I don't think you
can make a compelling case that fauci
was hiding things because he was funding
weaponized viruses in places I think
that that is a selective read
uh of it now can you blame Tony fauci a
little bit for the narrative yeah but
he's not a politician
um do I think that it is wrong to
question the use of vaccines no do I
think it is wrong to question what they
knew about this vaccine and what they
learned over time no
but base it off the data do I think that
it's simple enough to say we should have
never had the vaccine absolutely not
absolutely not uh oh but they exaggerate
the deaths
well no it's about what they were
learning about deaths over time
and comorbidity and that is not a new
Dynamic by the way in scientific
understanding for instance I'll give you
I'll give you a great example of this
there's nothing to do with covet okay
um
high LDL cholesterol heart disease right
not anymore
science is different now
turns out that uh there are a lot of
other coefficients that you got to take
into concern and that high LDL and
animal fat and a meat-based Diet isn't
an automatic heart attack coming your
way that you got to look at other things
you got to look at insulin absorption
tolerance and all these different
coefficients of all these different
little numbers and formulas and
algorithms well what happened I thought
it was that simple not anymore why the
facts change if I was a food Paradigm
guy
am I going to change my position now
what I've been telling you the pyramid
goes this way the whole time am I going
to flip it no I'm a dead man I am a dead
man you guys kill me here they kill me
I'll Meet the Press they kill me in the
Washington Post my opponents say he's a
flip-flopper
that's the difference and and we play to
Advantage more than we do uh to what is
right for the most people in the moment
and I see it again and again and again
okay so I got two clips I want to show
you okay on well what you're saying um I
think fauci was uh in a
rather he was very divisive when you
read the book the first thing I looked
at when I read his book uh it was such a
technical book to read but the things
got 30 000 reviews on Amazon and it sold
a lot of copies and nobody from the
other side came to really analyze or
tear it apart and saying these are not
credible sources what he did with AIDS
back in the days with the drug that was
making more money and Howard was
involved and what things he did all
these other things we can set that aside
on what fauci did play these two clips
one of them is from the media side and
then go to the Chuck Schumer one the
first one is a clip I was talking about
Rob play this one here so this is where
uh I'm kind of glad you're you're now on
your own doing your own stuff go play
play this if you can go for it hi I'm
Fox San Antonio's Jessica Headley and
I'm Ryan Wolfe our greatest
responsibility is to serve our Treasure
Valley communities the El Paso Las
Cruces communities Eastern Iowa
communities Mid Michigan communities
we're extremely proud of the quality
balanced journalism that cbs4 news
produces
[Music]
the sharing of biased and false news has
become all too common on social media
media Outlets publish keep going no keep
going same fake stories without checking
facts first the sharing of biased false
news
[Music]
this is extremely dangerous to our
democracy right the only like for
example I run a sales company right for
the last 23 years I've ran a sales
organization so for us everything I'll
never forget one time we're at an event
in Palm Springs and you know we're
competing with other agencies and I get
up and I said look look at my sales guys
on how scripted they are I had 250 guys
stand up and I gave objections verbatim
they overcame a next next objection
verbatim though 10 minutes we're doing
this like oh my God I don't have my guy
scripted that well when I saw this the
first thing I thought about is the only
way you can be this scripted is for
somebody to feed it to you in a
collective effort and it's not like it's
just fox or it's just NBC it's everybody
so you said something I want to kind of
go through the full question and I'll
give it back to you I see this and you
say well you can't call out the media
and call them fake news they're going to
come after you're 100 right you're 100
right you do that they're going to come
after you but for the longest time they
have been coming after the other people
so it's kind of like look guys you can
get away with murder I'm gonna give you
a little bit of a taste of your own
medicine then Schumer in an interview
with Rachel Maddow I think this is in
2017 if you can play this clip
opportunity
so I am
I was distraught right after the
election but I'm now actually
invigorated by The Challenge and our
ability to succeed in this challenge let
me ask you I don't know if you have seen
this I don't want to Blindside you with
this this is uh this is um the latest
statement latest tweets as you were just
saying the president-elect's latest
unsolicited pronouncement on the
intelligence Community this was his
tweet just a little while ago tonight
did you see the scare quotes there the
intelligence briefing on so-called
Russian hacking was delayed until Friday
perhaps more time needed to build a case
very strange we're actually told
intelligent sources tell NBC News since
this tweet has been posted that actually
this intelligence briefing for the
president-elect was always planned for
Friday it hasn't been delayed but he's
taking these
shot this antagonism is taunting to the
intelligence Community you take on the
intelligence Community they have six
ways from Sunday at getting back at it
so even for a practical support brother
I got to tell you really dumb to do this
what do you think the intelligence
Community would do if they were I don't
know but I from what I am told they are
very upset with how he has treated them
and talked about them and we need the
intelligence Community we don't know
what's going look at the Russian hacking
without the intelligence Community we
wouldn't have uh discovered it
you can pause let me actually see what
he says at the end I want to hear what
she said to try to dismantle parts of
the intelligence Community I mean this
form of let me talk whether you're a
super liberal Democrat or a very
conservative Republican you should be
against dismantling the intelligence
okay so so so I watched this as a guy
who
is a business guy and I've never been
through a pandemic before I lived in
Iran 10 years I've been through War
before I know what the war is and
[__] stuff that you can do to cause
more innocent people that have lived in
a refugee camp couple years came out I
was in a U.S Army hunter first I kind of
seen it from the other side when I was
kind of having to take the vaccine
anthrax was coming out and they're like
you guys kind of have to take it and you
well I don't want to take it and we kind
of got away from not taking it so and
then I'm hearing my friends who have to
take it or else they have to get out so
we interviewed some people that got out
after being there 14 years six years
away from retirement dude I don't want
to take the vaccine they kick me out I'm
kind of like going through this I'm like
look I don't I don't really know what's
going on I got the kobit uh myself and I
lost 21 pounds in a span of two weeks so
it was not good for me so it's not like
I'm sitting here so Kobe didn't do [__]
for me now some people are like it was
it was tough on me I was in a we were
moving everything from there to you and
I had covered we're getting tested on
the same day we run into each other we
came up to you in the car you looked so
skinny and pale it was very weird my my
wife doesn't see me for a few days I
come they keep putting food I can't eat
anything and I'm in a corner room
throwing up and I'm like dude this [__]
is you know this is kind of legit and
then Tom went into uh what were you were
in call you weren't I see you were in uh
yeah I did in seven days at ICU seven
days in ICU so because oxygen levels
kept dropping and I don't smoke I'm
obviously no comorbidities no lupus or
anything like that and there I was
oxygen levels couldn't stay up it's like
so so the reason why I'm saying all this
stuff to you is this is not a you know a
place of no it's this no I saw people
get it boom I saw 600 of our sales guys
get it after a conference of Sebastian
Maniscalco gets on stage and he's got a
mask in the back and he doesn't want to
shake hands I'm like Sebastian you got
covered no I'm just not feeling like
[__] you kind of look like you got
covered but it's like well I'm gonna do
it anyways because you're paying a guy
to perform so he kept this word which I
loved he comes up he says comes up he
said hey okay so welcome to the super
spreader events you know in Las Vegas so
so the reason why I'm sharing this with
you and I also had a board meeting one
day where all my board members are
telling me you got to get everybody in
the company vaccinated and I said I
can't do that so for me I'm not
vaccinated I didn't take the vaccine I
didn't take uh the booster my wife did
him but my dad did my nanny did a lot of
people in my life did but also didn't
take Ivermectin or hydroxyl chloroquine
so it's not like it's we're part of a
camp when I watched all this stuff that
was going on I sat there and I said no
wonder America doesn't trust the media
no wonder we don't trust fauci no wonder
whatever Chuck Schumer said there he was
right we learn how much power the doj
has how do you get up and say the doj
can ruin your life this guy's been
indicted 50 million times all this stuff
that they're doing to him so one sister
and says Chris you were on the outside
bro this is the kind of stuff that
caused us to not trust anybody now that
you're somewhat on the outside you're
still with news Nation but you got your
own show now you see the reason why
American people lost Trust in Media well
no I don't see it differently now look I
I can't say this strongly enough
I do not believe and I have never
experienced and look people couldn't
like what I do don't like what I do you
know they answer your question is why I
sound different is we've never had a
conversation before is that most
exposure to what I do is things taken in
clips and put out into a context that
people wanted to be in I don't believe
in the First Amendment you know you
can't download things all this [__]
that people say about me is just playing
to an agenda an advantage and that's
okay that's the price of Entry but
that's why I sound different that we've
never spoken before I'm not different
um nobody ever told me what to say or
not say at CNN and I would have told
them to take a walk if they did and I
don't know about any conspiracy to go
after anybody other than what's obvious
and Chuck Schumer saying that about the
intelligence uh committee he needs to
explain uh his context on it I don't
disagree with his assessment I mean I
feel the same way when I tell people
what's going to happen if uh they start
messing with a cop during a stop I mean
which way do you think this is going to
go not that cops are evil but do you
think it's going to go well for you if
you start [__] talking a cop during a
traffic stop do you think good things
are going to happen so I just think when
you mess with people with power you got
to be careful what was he alluding to uh
I don't know did he create an article of
convenience for people who want to
defend Trump absolutely that's politics
you got to be careful what you say
one of the reasons we haven't spoken
before is
and I come here in good faith and I
believe uh that pbd podcast I've watched
about 14 of them 15 of them
um you come from a good place you're a
straight shooter about what you believe
and why I think you can get carried away
with things but that's within the realm
of choice
um I don't do a lot of this because
people clip it up and use it to promote
crazy things that I don't believe and I
don't say and I can't correct
um so I just never really spoke about it
and I never really defended myself
because what is true what is group think
and not just at CNN but at ABC and at
Fox before that is they're very careful
about having you defend a proposition
when really you'll probably just give it
more oxygen
um and that and things go away
especially now with all this media
there's also less attention span so we
move from one thing to the next so the
best advice in a crisis is always just
if there's no process attached shut up
and it'll move on and I have borne that
burden many times I mean I the the
you could play a list of clips of things
that uh people weaponize about me I
could defend every single one and I have
no problem doing it whether it's the
Shelter Island thing I have answers for
all of them anything I've ever said
that's wrong
I've corrected
uh and and you're gonna say things that
are wrong by the way you know what I
mean you're on live TV totally fine but
anything where Cuomo says Uh there's the
protests are not meant to be uh where
does it say protests are supposed to be
peaceful it has millions of views on the
internet like I don't know what the you
know what the first amendment is
well what's the context
some of the early
um George Floyd uh protests you got
black people their allies angry yelling
in the face of cops you know either spit
coming out of them or you know flying
out of their mouths because they're so
angry and people are disgusted want them
to go home and I say hey protests will
be angry
people are going to say things that you
don't want to hear it's going to be mean
there's going to be hateful speech the
cops are going to take you know a verbal
beating
but here's the part you never heard the
moment you touch person or property you
become a criminal you become what you
oppose and it's a riot now I know Dr
King had a different explanation of a
riot being you know sometimes the
desperation of the voiceless but in the
law it's a crime
I don't get that I get that I said who
said protests are supposed to be
peaceful why because it makes me look
like an idiot and Advance a cause that I
am defending the BLM people in a way
that I don't defend I don't know some
other group is that true no it's not
even close to true well then how come I
never said this because who would have
given a [__]
the people who want to believe that they
want to believe it they're going to
believe it
Cuomo said we can't download Wikileaks I
never said that it is unclear under the
Espionage Act what happens when a
citizen downloads a cache of classified
information
we don't know within the reading of the
law it could be a problem the media
because of the Pentagon papers has
gotten more leeway
I say you're probably going to wind it
you got to be careful with this stuff
you're probably going to wind up hearing
a lot about it from us
so it played as this deep State media
control over your mind thing
I published or whatever broadcasts
communicated everything that came out
that they gave us I didn't censor
anything I didn't keep anything from you
so why does that clip have a gazillion
views because it feeds a narrative that
works for people and that's the price of
Entry I get it I don't like it
I think it's irresponsible but it works
it works really well you will not find a
compendium of Genius statements from
Chris Cuomo that has millions of hits on
it but you will find millions of hits of
[__] things that are taken out of
context I'm guaranteeing you that Chuck
Schumer is not the past key to an
understanding that the Deep State
decided to take down Donald Trump and
you have to be you don't you don't
believe that at all I do not believe are
you saying you're zero like there's no
way in the world there is a deep state
that went after a guy that was
challenging The Establishment and and
saying he's going to come here try to
drain the swamp you know this is not a
guy that's a typical guy that gets
elected the last guy that we had like
Trump as a president one would say was
probably Kennedy we've never I don't I
don't mean from this thing nothing I
don't mean from the standpoint of
Personality take personality out I don't
mean from the standard I was a Senator a
member of Congress who was a veteran who
came from a story his family was a
pretty anti-establishment family I don't
know if I would put Kennedy's notice I
didn't even say Reagan I'm this is not a
uh Republican thing I'm doing here to
say well the last anti-establishment he
was a two-term governor I'm saying the
last person we had I don't think Kennedy
is a good analog for Trump you don't
think Kennedy was an anti-establishment
family where they went up to say what
they're going to do to the FED to CIA
what they were going to do to stop in a
war you don't think any of that was is
anti-establishment reasons no I don't
see it as anti-establishment I see it as
him him making what he believed to be
reason choices uh he did what few
leaders can do which is learn from a
mistake with the Bay of Pigs so maybe
let me ask this question why do you
think he got assassinated do you think
it was just a mob was not happy the fact
that they didn't give him because a mob
helped them with Dewey in Chicago and he
thought he needed it eventually he
didn't need it and that's why they're
getting back I think that there were
elements that certainly uh included mob
influence that were unhappy with what
they thought was an arrangement I think
that a lot of the Animus was towards
Bobby Kennedy I believe uh the idea
until proven otherwise remember Bobby
Kennedy
um you're not only embarrassed which I
would say it's not embarrassed when
you're a felon but the way one of the
mob guys was treated was seen as insult
but they have a perverse sense of insult
because they're criminals
um you know he said Italians are
predisposed to criminality Bobby Kennedy
you know that's uh you know it's not a
nice thing to say about Italian
Americans but
I believe they had animus towards him
and I believe the theory until proven
otherwise release the file and then I'll
say I'm wrong that the decision was made
that look if you're going to go after
somebody you better go after the
president because he's going to come
after us if we go after his brother so
you don't believe anything with LBJ the
CIA I don't have reason to believe
we can speculate you have a basis for it
I gotta see the data release the file
and then I'll give you an answer yeah
see what I'm saying let transparency
build the trust no no I get that I mean
for us but I'm telling you I don't know
first of all I don't know that that clip
with all the local stations saying that
I I want to reserve some skepticism of
editing and to make sure that somebody
didn't just make it sound like they're
all saying the same thing but I never
saw any script like that I definitely
have concerns about fake news and people
who are telling you things that are
untrue but weaponizing the idea that you
can't trust the media you can only trust
them uh and the idea that the former
president tells the truth more often
than I do is demonstrably false
um but that's politics that's fine I
have a different standard I'm not
running for anything I'm not asking for
anybody's vote
um but
I think it's dangerous and I think it's
untrue I think the media you take like
you take any other business
Outlet by Outlet platform by platform
person by person
I am not Leland vidert is not Dan Abrams
is not Ashley Banfield
um if if you like me it doesn't mean or
you dislike me it doesn't mean you
should dislike them those are your
colleagues on news Nation so that that's
probably one of the best town halls was
done news Nation RFK my favorite one so
far
I thought it was good for news Nation to
do it I think the idea that you don't do
it because Bobby says things that can be
untrue or that can be seen as disruptive
is a mistake uh what you do is you let
him say it you ask him for his basis of
it you test his basis and what did you
see in the Town Hall Bobby did a lot of
backpedaling why because he's making
positions through a different lens now
which is not just to push an extreme
Reckoning of something that has a basis
of marginal justification but now he's
trying to form consensus I thought he
crushed it see I thought he cried I
thought when she asked the question
about
you know a drug addiction all this stuff
and he just went straight up when I was
28 years old after my father died I had
a 14-year addiction with this and he
just kind of opened it up and then when
she said hey what do you think about
Trump this is look I like the fact that
you know I I you know I like I don't
want to go directly after Biden I don't
want to insult anybody I want to have a
relationship I just disagree I thought
the way he handled this yeah I agree now
it reads his weakness and of being a
tool for the right you know and being
but that's where we are in our politics
now and the media will allow that to be
said also look again I don't cover Bobby
Kennedy Jr as closely and in person
because I have a conflict okay now I
believe that it's a BS conflict I can
absolutely be fair to Bobby positive and
negative but I I'm sensitive to the
perception now because of what I lived
through with my brother
um so that's why I mean also you you
know you got a uh they leveled up with
Elizabeth Vargas I mean you know she's
the top of the food chain so uh it was
better than what she had before by the
way ABC News oh okay but the I've worked
with it for years I mean Top Notch so
that you know they benefited from her
doing it in instead of me that's for
sure but
um Bobby is saying things differently
now you know he's used by people who are
anti-vaxxers
what's the first thing he says I'm not
anti-vaccine yeah now did he used to say
that as loud and proud but no why but he
was coming from a different place that's
politics I'm not saying he's lying I
think it's an act or do you think that's
really who he is no it's about messaging
it's about consensus you know how I know
it's real one night my wife and I were
in Dallas
and our kids are going to this Christian
school private school
and all of a sudden the school's like we
need the vaccination cards updated
and our first two kids took everything
anything they need to take they've taken
it you know
and uh then after I have a meeting with
Robert said look just you may want to
not do this you may want to not do this
you may want to not he says look here's
how many vaccines you took and I'm like
dude I was in the Army first I took 11
shots I don't even know what I've taken
right when you join the army they do the
gunshots on your you know so he says
well yeah when I took it it was only
three then they went to 12 then they
went to this and today's 72 and he's
just kind of give me the history and I'm
looking I'm like yeah that's kind of
true why do we need so many vaccines no
problem
it's 11 o'clock at night
Jennifer says babe what do we do with
this they need this car tomorrow
I said babe we're not going to give it
to him tomorrow they can send us home if
they want we're not going to do that so
I send a text to Bobby
11 o'clock Eastern uh Central Standard
Time which is midnight his time I'm like
he's not going to respond but he'll call
me first thing in the morning
30 seconds he texts back then he gets on
the phone with me for 45 minutes he's
finding people to do a conference call
with us on how the kids don't have to
take all the vaccines an hour later this
guy could be with his family doing a
bunch of different things I got off the
phone I'm looking at Jen I'm like
this is when you know this guy's a 100
percent True Believer in this there is
no act with this there's no questioning
the basis of his advocacy
okay the accuracy of the positions is
subject to testing like anything else
I'm not questioning the guy's heart I'm
not questioning his head
but he has to make the case as to a
matter of degree on the positions and
that's fine
um but I look people who want to write
them off as something look I I thought
what the member of Congress said the
other day and look you know he's got the
right to his own opinion but him going
after the guy's family and you're
mocking the Kennedy name
uh you know I think that's way out of
bounds it's way out of bounds uh and I
think that you know one you don't get to
judge somebody standing in their own
family and two you know all the pain
that this guy's lived through
and you you're my father and his uncle
and you're not going to talk to him his
wife uh you know the all his personal
pain his siblings and you're gonna
you're gonna talk to him about his
family
um so look everybody can feel any way
they want I'm saying something else
and this is really the only thing that
matters
you have to get back to disagreeing with
decency and not because it's nice to be
nice
it's that nothing else works
nothing else Works in a democracy except
the marketplace of ideas were the best
ideas win
that's all that works and the only way
place you get is where we're flying
toward which is where there's all kinds
of [__] in the ether that people believe
very passionately but without any basis
because you don't even know who they are
or what they're saying uh or they're
taking things out of context or they're
taking a little thing over here they're
pretending that this person is that
person
um and it works for a campaign
it just works well for a two-party
system
it just does it's gonna happen with
Bobby like what's the outcome with him
like you were very clear that he's going
to lose everything that's happened with
Biden the fundraising uh he's gonna lose
he's capped at about 20 percent we've
seen some fall off from that because of
the increased level of scrutiny I don't
think that he can get a constituency
within the Democrats that would want him
to replace Biden
um I think that you know they have
trouble uh they're raising a ton of
money
they have polls the Monmouth poll other
polls you know the polls are just a
snapshot in time you don't know who the
sample is you don't know what it is it's
it's helpful uh over a course of
multiple data points for a suggestive
Trend but there's only one poll that
matters trite but true and that's on
Election Day
um but
Biden's numbers are still strong enough
and the money raising is still strong
enough for them to sit down on the point
that he is not projecting what you would
want from somebody who's going to be in
as big a fight as what they anticipate
and I think that the lack of build out
of the staff I think the lack of uh
rah-rah
should just it to me justifies what I
hear about concern from deep pocket
donors and if you he's going to lose so
that means Biden's going to be just
sauntering into the look I don't mean to
condemn Bobby's Fates I'm I'm not an
oracle I'm just saying that you on the
Democrat side if the party doesn't want
you you got a big problem we learned
that with Bernie why would he run as a
Democrat I don't even understand like he
cannot switch no he says he's a Democrat
yeah I totally get that but you're not
gonna like you're you're not gonna what
do you like why would you not for the
exact reason for exact reason that you
like him
that's what he believes yeah that's why
he's doing it this is what I believe so
if Biden's the guy and trumps the guy
again we saw this movie you you said
quite poignantly the sequel's never good
as the first time around how ugly is
2024 election going to be when it's
Biden Trump round two
I mean uh you know as ugly as it can get
because that's what works
and you know look it's much harder you
know if you think about it the Greeks
gave us the word demagogue right uh
somebody who plays on anger outrage and
Prejudice to gather support very old
word
no positive opposite
why
because it's easier to go that way it
works you play to what somebody's scared
look look at the vaccine stuff
you play to what something I'm afraid
you don't know what they're shooting
into you people believe that there's
nanotechnology in the vaccine that is
allowing big brother to control you
um not a shred of evidence of that
but it goes to my fear the economy
diversky the psychologists who won the
um the um Nobel Prize for economics they
distilled this principle that if you
offer somebody a hundred bucks right now
or give them a coin toss on a thousand
they take the hundred there's no
statistical analysis that would support
that unless you're a hundred dollars
from Death you know what I mean and then
you just take what you have people play
scared they play to self-protection they
play it safe so if you can trigger that
this is a threat to you
especially if it goes to family or your
kids their health
it is powerful way more than give me a
hug
way more than I know you guys don't
share everything but you share a lot
more than you think don't be afraid of
him get past your fear that's hard
and sure they can show your kids
my kids all the kids of different colors
in the beginning they're all they all
like each other why yeah that's nature
versus nurture it's not what our world
is it's what our world could be right
it's it's what all the great religions
are trying to teach us in terms of an
ecumenical
um you know standard of of self-respect
and respect of others but that's not
where we are
we're talking about Schumer earlier so
uh talking about you I think your
brother's got a few million dollars in a
pack I think I read it like a couple
weeks ago I may be wrong but so meaning
he can still do something and run again
and I don't know what he's going to run
for but uh you know when when when covet
happened and you're seeing him talk and
you're seeing him do what he's doing and
you know I think him and AOC and de
Blasio had a issue I don't know what it
was over Amazon Bezos was going to move
him he's got 125 000 or 25 000 jobs at
150 000 salary and aoc's like this is
not fair it's going to increase render
and then your brother's like what are
you talking about we need these jobs
here and de Blasio and AOC were United
so it's not like your brother's a de
Blasio AOC no fart he's not that guy no
and then I'm like okay so he understands
capitalism for him to say yes bring the
good jobs here and then you're seeing
the way he's handling it he would also
poke back at Trump uh that's probably
the benefit of being raised in a family
that probably talks a lot of [__] to
each other and you've been in the
Limelight where you can have a thicker
skin that you can handle you're like I
can handle Trump and then you're like
this guy could actually do something in
my mind the book comes out makes the
money
he gets the criticism for uh uh the book
and then the 13 14 000 people that you
know the the old folks homes that he
gets criticism for that but but the part
that was weird for me uh Chris and I'm
curious what you'll say to this
it wasn't like the Republicans or
even New Yorkers turn on the guy my
feeling was I could be wrong I felt like
the Pelosi's and Schumer's turned
against him and they're like this guy's
getting a little bit so so then I'm
going in my own mind against speculation
I don't know I'm not you and I don't
commit this is the first time you and I
have talked face to face it's important
for the audience to know this we've
exchanged text we've never never had a
phone call together this is actually the
first time
um I'm sitting there saying
dude so this [__] about
anti-establishment doesn't exist
okay and Cuomo Andrew seems like a guy
that could actually do what his father
didn't want to do maybe this guy
actually wants to do it
did these guys flip on him because
behind closed doors he told them hey
screw you leave me alone I'm gonna run
my state I'm a Democrat I'm going to be
loyal publicly to you guys but don't
come and tell me what to do and threaten
me all this other stuff I'm gonna do
what I do because maybe in the next
couple years he's going to run is there
any speculation to maybe the pelosis and
Schumer's felt they couldn't control him
so they threw him under the bus
I mean you know is there speculation
about it I suppose uh but it's not it's
not my opinion
um and obviously Andrew makes his own
case answers for himself
he's in a party party has rules okay
um and the allegations against him broke
the party's rules
did he have a basis of love and wanting
to protect him within the party
um certainly not a sufficient one was
that because of jealousy or was it
because of principle I don't know you're
going to have to ask the people that
decided to support him or not support
him but I don't see any conspiracy uh
behind it I just see a lot of pain and
look
my brother
is a mechanic okay that's what he is
Andrew is a master mechanic engines
uh like literally he is a Master
Mechanic and he fixes that's what Andrew
does
he is always trying yes he's my brother
yes I love him to death yes I'll defend
him to death
but if there is a defense that is Merit
based it's
he thinks he's trying to fix
and that's all he sees
and that's his perspective
so the oh yeah but you know this guy
doesn't really like you and you got to
spread the love and you got it
he's not the guy
um and he's not going to be the most
popular the media did not like him
um people will put that unlikability you
talk to his family you talk to his
friends he's plenty likable if he wants
you to like him uh he's not looking to
get uh buddy buddy with people that he
doesn't respect and he doesn't
appreciate in terms of what his his own
goals are during the pandemic
and you know you don't have to you don't
have to believe me but I don't know what
my motivation would be to lie
um I never talked to him about running
for president never I I never
uh saw that the only thing I would say
is because remember I'm his brother okay
the few people understand the media
better than I do just as a matter of
experience not intelligence you know how
can you do something 25 plus you'd not
know no question about it so
um
I was worried about exposure I was
worried about uh you know with the
president of the United States getting
sideways with you you know it's not that
Andrew is a trash talker it's that
Andrew hates trash talk
uh you know like like when we would play
basketball
me pop love Trash Talk
um I love talking trash I love it I
somehow don't get that vibe from me
Andrew I'm being sarcastic I hope you
take that as a company yeah go ahead
Andrew it's not a trash talk yeah
um really yeah in fact the only person
I've ever seen him really take the piss
out of on a regular basis is me but you
know I'm his brother and that's our
relationship but
Andrew is a do not say guy you know like
I always say you know when we do
self-defense uh when I do self-defense
training I I always say you know if
someone's talking we're in good shape
we're in good shape you know pbd can be
saying I'm about to knock your head off
as long as he's saying it
I still got a chance here to get out of
it Andrew is not going to say [__] okay
it's like you know if it's gonna happen
it's gonna happen
um so for him it's not a banter of the
war of words he he doesn't want that he
wants to get things done he wants to
figure out if there's a deal to be made
and if you want to fight then you're
going to get a fight
so that's his disposition that has not
changed he has not been changed by this
he's been forged by this experience he
is more him
than
ever I protected his kids he protected
his family he did what he could uh I do
believe public service is in his bones
um that gives me concern as a brother
and someone who loves him I think he's
done enough I think he's given enough
um
but he's gonna he's a player though he's
going to make him he's going to make his
own choices look I think it is hard for
somebody who believes that the Mandate
is from the people not the powerful
to have anything end in service without
it coming from them
lose an election lose an election like
my pop 1994.
all the polls have him personal pretty
good performance the economies in the
tank the predominance uh social issue
culture War at the time is a death
penalty he would not shut up about being
against the death penalty as vehemently
as he was that was not the popular
position
he was going to lose
he knew he was going to lose
Andrew said you're going to lose Andrew
said you're gonna yeah well it was good
I mean that was not a genius stroke you
know I mean it's like he was losing the
whole time and it he said but I gotta
run and he said we're gonna lose he said
then I lose
but I don't not fight
I do not not fight I do not believe that
what Al D'Amato and George Pataki want
for this state is the right thing I'm
going to fight and if I lose I lose I
get lost
and it hurt him but it came from the
people
accepted it Andrew's the same way
um and look
I would much rather have him than who we
have today and I think a lot of people
feel the same way and if he was on the
other side going up against trump it
would have been very natural and quite
frankly
purely out of a guy that loves
competition you know Messi yesterday
score scored a goal down the street two
miles away from here he scored a goal
the place went insane game winner with
94 minutes you know and and take the
back step see and this is such an
interesting instruction in our culture
Messi wasn't feeling well or something
like that or he's injured
he is getting dressed so I'm down here
in South Florida right this is a huge
thing for you guys he is getting dragged
what a money play what [__] he's not
gonna play all the ticket prices popped
and he's not even going to be in the guy
levels up goes in game-winning goals
show the goal if you can uh this was so
simple but this is our culture right now
hate him hate him hate him hate him hate
him boom he's a hero right yeah and look
it's fine in sports it's why we love
sports
but
man oh man this this you know I get a
call from Mario by the way I get a call
from Mario I'm so upset I didn't go to
the game everybody's like how crazy was
it were you at the I'm like one mile
away I totally had no idea last night
I don't think he even he didn't start
the game no but look that's the point is
that we have become so reactionary
hate him hate him hate them love them
love them love them and does the media
play into its sure it look it's a big
part of what the mission of news nation
is and I know that that can be confusing
and confounding pick a side
there is a side it's your side
wherever your interests lay that's the
way you cover whatever it is that's
going on you are the voice box for the
people you are their proxy with the
powerful let's stay on this with Andrew
so December of last year he has a
meeting in New York with kellyanne
Conway okay they've been friends for a
long time of course and and you know
that's I've been friends with her for 30
years
she's a beast by the way I mean she's an
absolutely that's not the word that I
would use well I would say on TV she's a
she's she's formidable she to us as a
compliment so that's a very much of a
compliment it's a good thing no no she's
first of all very attractable what I
mean is she's a she's a super competitor
and then story comes out she's smiling
he's smiling then three months later
she's getting a divorce it's very March
of 2023 she's gonna go down the rabbit
hole I'm just asking you a question so
so so then I'm sitting there saying okay
there's a friendship kellyanne is smart
enough to know this is going to be
pictures are going to be taking Andrew
and those pictures are going to be taken
if you're doing this you don't give a
[__] if these pictures are going to be
taken publicly so that's fine that's
right but then three months later that
happens now George Conway to be fair uh
he's part of the Lincoln project Group
which is kind of like not the most
friendly of who she is and then we've
seen you know Conway the daughter the
the Snapchat videos are very weird
Dynamics there yeah so
is there is there a uh uh do you want to
know if my brother's with kellyanne
Conway is that what you're asking no
that's not what I'm asking well we don't
play is that what you want to know no
but by the way they look very good
together for what it's for I saw them
I'm like they look like a couple do they
not look like a couple coming up well
there are a couple of people coming out
at the same time that looks like a nice
couple looking you know people coming
out but uh you know if he runs again
would it be something more for a New
York or would it be more something
National
oh I don't know that's for him okay uh
that's for him I mean look it's hard to
take a Cuomo out of New York uh it's
it's uh it's so deep again in the marrow
um but that's that's for him to decide
uh to do nothing do anything else the
man is incredibly capable is he loved
still
in New York
look I would have to believe it depends
on the moment that yeah so if he goes to
restaurants that they're making paper
yeah yeah they're still making pay for
it well he better pay really yeah uh you
there's nothing for free brother because
you know you're like uh uh you know uh
no no he gets a lot of love in fact yeah
that's what I'm I'll tell you how it is
when when uh we were going through what
I call the troubles
and
I would say to him I came out more right
because I look I'm not gonna hide all
right that's not how I am I had to hide
a little bit in the beginning because
they were killing my family
um
so anyway
I say to him you know you should come
out on the boat with me a little bit he
got me into boating he got me into
fishing you know I mean he's he's the
big brother he everything I know about
cars and old hot rods which were both
very uh active with I I learned from him
so
I said you know let's go I don't want to
cause any trouble I don't want any
trouble I said there's not going to be
trouble
even
the reddest of the red Trump hat wearer
when they see Andrew
would come up to him and again Andrew's
a big you know he's like pbd's size so
it's like you know I don't know what you
were expecting but yeah he's not the guy
you're going to run up to six four how
big is he and start talking a lot of
trash
um no he's like his side so
they would come up to him and say
I don't agree with you politics
I don't like what happened to you uh I I
think you believed in what you were
doing uh I appreciate what you did
during the pandemic
um I'm sorry about what happened it's
wrong what they did to you now some of
them it's just I hate Democrats so I'm
going to say that you know the enemy of
my enemy is my friend
um but
I'm telling you it's overwhelming
response now I'm not saying that they
won't show a poll and that Democrats
aren't upset at them or that he's lost
approval or his numbers are down I'm
sure all of that's true
but politics is about a moment in time
and what you present in that moment uh
what your message is and whether it
resonates or not in the vessel of you as
a messenger
um and I think the future's wide open
for him he's incredibly talented
I personally okay I got his back 100
whatever he wants to do I'm there he's
my brother she makes her at news Nation
if he runs don't interview him I don't
think that's right don't you think that
that would be in the cards although I'll
tell you what though on the podcast
different story I'll tell you what look
to me I'm just you know I don't want to
I don't want any more you know what I
mean like I can't I don't want any more
smoke I don't want any more smoke I mean
I can take the smoke I'm built for the
smoke but I'm pre-smokey so people quit
smoking people ask me all the time
for those interviews
I would love that again I'd love to see
you guys talking and you razzing him
about what it is that he does and being
a politician and all that I really liked
great TV but here's the problem that
takes us back to the big problem which
is why I'm at news Nation
there is group think and there is
cultural bias within media and every
system
there is a disconnect between the people
watching this this is different because
podcasts are more curated to Their
audience
and the media itself
there are different standards I've never
had a regular person say to me
I can't believe you interviewed your
brother uh you know you should have been
asking him the hard questions
never because that makes no sense okay
uh to a regular person I get why people
in the media feel differently about it
okay
but
that disconnect you know the media would
be go crazy if I was in the same media
setting with my brother
people would probably love it so what do
you do from his perspective
you you do it from my perspective you
don't because the media will kill me and
I got to exist in the media and I'm not
pbd you guys have your you're in the
media writ large but you're not
journalists and you are not subject to
journalists appraisals and you can say
all but people don't care listen
when they say whenever they want Chris
Cuomo Kama fired for lying to CNN comma
it hurts and it doesn't just hurt
because it's untrue it hurts because it
it echoes
and that's what it is for me you can say
whatever you want about me helping my
brother you can say what you want about
me helping my brother while I was
working at CNN
you're free to have your opinion I
didn't lie
um and that matters that that matters so
I think his future is wide open he's
going to have to determine it
I know he'll talk to me about it
um you know we don't always agree on
everything
um I hate the two-party system I think
it is the problem
I don't even think it's part of the
problem I think it is the problem I get
that people say yeah but third party all
you're going to do is be a spoiler for
nothing changes if nothing changes so if
that's not the best change then what is
it and why isn't part of the analysis
from the Democrat side well let's say
Biden
doesn't muster the entire time
don't you want someone out there who's
generating some type of basis of support
to become a Counterpoint to Trump if he
is the candidate there that you're so
worried about or do you really just want
to be
one or none
quick question on brotherhood since
you're talking about your brother
again Pat and I loved everything you
guys were doing it was amazing amazing
TV we talked about Brotherhood a lot
we've had a two podcasts with Andrew
Tate talk about masculinity Brotherhood
everything with that Pat's an army guy I
was a football guy Brotherhood we
understand that
you know on CNN
it seemed as if like your brother you
were his closest Brothers was your buddy
Don Lemon or as Pat calls him Don Lemon
especially because of my English
language since
you're firing from CNN he's also been
fired yeah uh what happened with that
situation and how close are you guys
these days
look what happened to me at CNN hurt a
lot of my relationships
what I control is what I say and do and
how I feel
I was very upset that Don lost his
position at CNN
um I want all good things for him
our our situation is now complicated
because
I was fired
explained as having been
a negative
force on CNN a deceptive force to a
place he cares about
and there was a narrative put out
about
why our boss was fired that was set up
to blame me for something I had nothing
to do with it doesn't even make sense
but this takes time and takes time to
process you know and and this isn't a
hedge I mean relationships are
complicated
um I care a lot about him I want good
things for him he's ridiculously
talented
um but
what they did to me there hurt me uh and
hurt relationships
uh and created an environment where a
lot of the people who were close to me
aren't now
out of you know what they were
instructed uh you know what they sensed
uh what they were told what they decided
to believe
and uh life is long and what I know is I
want good things
for him and I have never faked the funk
on TV
if I care about somebody I care about
him if I don't I don't say anything I
call a lot of people brother because I
believe in fraternity I believe that we
have to do everything we can to
reinforce our connections to each other
and some people will say that's not the
job of a journalist I don't agree
I think advocacy is a component of
things that are right and righteous
there is good and bad there is right and
wrong sometimes it's great and you have
to pursue the different aspects of it
that's why I love crime and that's why
at news Nation we do so much crime but
the idea that I
don't like or are now enemies with
that's all [__] it's not true last
question
um when you had covid did you ever take
Ivermectin over a hydroxychloride did
you take any of those things no but only
because uh my doctors told me that
they didn't know REM dezavir also they
didn't know what it would do that there
was concern about side effects remember
I got it very early on
and also hydroxychloroquine as one drug
in particular
with people who had the pneumonia aspect
of it REM deservir there are pneumonia
applications for those drugs that wasn't
my thing although I did have a scare
where I started to get a shadow in one
lung
um where they became worried and they
gave me this spirometer thing and you
had to work on your lung capacity and I
was doing it all the time I was really
sick it really it really bothers me when
people play with that I get why they
play with it
um but you know it it bothers me the
idea that I was making [__] up or
anything like that I was doing just fine
I didn't need to make up something uh to
do well uh on television and I got that
long covet stuff afterwards and now I
don't know is it that I'm 53 is it that
I've gotten tackled and hit so much in
my life you know or that I've been
clanging and banging for so long I don't
know and they don't know enough about
long covet but I'm telling you my
resting breathing rate has never been
the same my VO2 max
the RPMs that my engine can get to were
still good but my idling is not what it
was
my ability to like walk and talk by my
breathing is not what it used to be my
soft tissue
um now again is it age you know there's
gonna be a lot of different things uh is
not what it was
um my blood levels
and my um inflammation markers are not
what they were and I kept getting it
I think I you know I I think I've had it
three times coven yeah damn which one
was the worst was it the first one that
was I never felt anything about it I
never felt anything like that I had
fever freaky I don't remember
a lot of doing the shows I had no idea
how the work was resonating
I had no idea I had no idea how many
people were watching it or anything like
that my day was like
you know I'm sure you can identify this
my day was like a haze of fever
meds my wife giving me all of these uh
homeopathic I would take anything so it
wasn't that I was never anti this or
anti that it was don't tell people this
is what you take to beat something we
don't even know what the hell it is and
it's and it's not even its primary
application you know I I didn't spend a
lot of time going after your uh your boy
Rogan and I understand why guys like him
or even Tucker there's a currency in
going after me because there was a
perception of what I represented on the
left it was never fair as an assessment
and if they spoke to me directly I
guarantee you they wouldn't have said
the same things that they say about me
um but
that's the price that that's the price
of entry and do I like it no do I accept
it yes that's why I'm at news Nation
um I believe that it's worth what comes
with it to try to do something that
helps and that's the best feedback I've
ever gotten in my life is what we do
there yes news nation's not weaponized
the way CNN was for the purposes of one
political agenda or another
but people say I've been looking for
this I've been looking for this because
the idea of all I want is the facts look
then get this if all you want the facts
do your homework
media is who what where and when but why
is an all-consuming question perspective
matters context matters testing matters
that is the most important part of the
job to me it's the part that matters
most I'll go back to Ukraine I'll go to
an area of conflict I'll do news
coverage of disasters I'd rather not do
hurricanes I think it's stupid uh to
stand out in whether that you're telling
people not to be in but you guys love it
so there's that but
testing power
you know going at McDonald's hey what's
the truth and not truth with the black
minority franchisees uh going at the
government these hearings next week look
I like Congressman Merchant I like where
his head's at
if this is the same stuff that we've
heard already and the guys who know more
aren't there that's a problem man and
that's a problem for congress
um the Kennedy assassination stuff oh we
got bigger problems that it is the root
the dossier
the Mueller probe
these hearings where they tell us they
believe they're going to be able to show
things but they don't show us things
it's it's feeding the problem we need a
lot more transparency we need a lot more
Let the ideas come out my problem with
the Twitter file I'm a big fan of
Michael schellenberger and taibi I don't
know uh Barry Weiss I I've heard and
read some of her stuff I I get why she
has a good reputation but I know them
I didn't like that musk picked who to
give the information to it breeds
distrust and I was worried for
schellenberger specifically because I
know him better that you're going to
become a Target now because people are
going to say well what choices were you
making with the data who would have been
better everyone
put it all out
create a file of what you think the
universe of uh valid information but
don't tie it to a face or a name that's
what you're saying just put it all out
don't give it to you and then you decide
what I know
decentralization I mean look if if
elon's
if elon's Elon musk's goal was to expose
then expose say what you want about
Wikileaks I don't know why I became an
enemy of theirs I really I really don't
get it like it's I really don't get it
but be that as it may
put it out and let people decide the
media will do their job
but take away the weapon of saying well
I haven't seen it for myself well that's
not everything take it out of the
equation
look if I'm the Biden team I'm telling
you about the payments now I get why the
experts will say
don't don't give air to that there's
nothing there let the prosecutors force
you to have to discuss it that is
absolutely the sage advice and if I'm
your lawyer and I'm a lawyer that's what
I'm telling you shut up let them make us
have to do something right the burden's
not on us that's not politics that's not
the court of public opinion if you want
to be seen as better than Trump
then show that you're better than Trump
otherwise you're not going to be able to
make the case as convincingly as you
could otherwise
would you want to say something I think
ultimately is Cuomo Cuomo 2024. it
wouldn't be me maybe one of my sisters I
run from office not for office it's not
for me bro you have my vote brother if
you win Andrew better if you can do
better thank you yeah if you and Andrew
if we did a podcast together we'd have a
couple hundred people here wanting to
watch and yeah we'd have cigars in the
back I think it'd be very entertaining
uh on doing that podcast but Chris this
has been it's interesting because when
we did the Anthony Weiner interview
yeah I said I said the father afterwards
rob you remember what I said I said let
me tell you over under there's a chance
Chris's Camp is going to tell him dude
you do not want to go there because you
don't know what Pat's going to be saying
and he's going to do this and he's going
to do that and I said yeah we'll see you
know and some people say Chris he's
still gonna show up I'm telling you
Chris still going to show up I said I
don't know I think uh he may or may not
because uh Anthony uh the the interview
that we had was a very much of a
combative from the beginning when he
came in it was a different interview
you're not Anthony Weiner I was looking
forward to doing this interview but I'm
also looking forward to doing the
Anthony Weiner interview but I actually
like what you your brother how you guys
are the family the Cuomo when you think
about last names and and by the way
here's the weirdest thing about our show
which I freaking love
um I'm doing business with this guy
we're about to sign a multi-year
contract with an Ott company and we're
launching a vitamin Ott the owner of the
company one of these is out of real
estate he's a multi-billion a very
well-known name he sees my interview
with Alex Jones
comes back he says we can't have like
famous Ott be with us
his salesperson who's a die-hard
validator follows our contacts and Pat
this is why they don't want to have the
Ott because you had Alex on okay
couple weeks later we have Anthony
weineron I'm getting text messages from
people saying Pat you've sold out you
this you that I said listen guys if
there is a place for all of us to be
able to talk together and have the
conversations you'd be the judge of it
you know you could say you know what he
made a good point I totally disagree
with them I can't even believe what
Patrick said that makes no sense no
problem my conversation is here you get
to say whatever you say you're the
audience or the people but the idea is
my favorite types of conversations are
these and have a lot of respect for you
for saying yes I have a lot of respect
for you for coming out here I ask you
say that that's the only reason I'm
coming out you're not out here with
family for vacation you're here to do
the podcast and go back so if you're
watching this you enjoyed it as much as
I did Rob let's put the link again below
to go and subscribe to uh Chris's uh
YouTube channel project the Cuomo uh the
Chris Cuomo project as well as his show
news Nation news Nation weeknights 8 P.M
uh once again when news Nation Chris
appreciate you for coming out gank have
a great weekend we'll do this again next
week take care everybody bye-bye bye-bye